Today's guest uses history to predict
wars, elections, and the end of the
world. What's your prediction for 2027?
All the ingredients for civil war should
already be in place. ICE will be much
more powerful than people imagine. The
global economy should have collapsed by
2027.
>> A son of Chinese immigrants in Toronto,
he grew up poor, invisible, and obsessed
with how power actually works.
>> There's no objective reality. Everything
is a creation of our imagination. What
we do every day is we participate in
reality. We create reality.
>> Now a high school history teacher in
China, he's predicted Trump winning the
election, America's invasion of
Venezuela, and recently the war between
Iran and the US.
>> There are three major vulnerabilities of
the American military. The first is
political will. The American population
is not supportive of this war. Second
issue is the lack of manufacturing
capacity. What America chose to do was
offshore its factories to China. Number
three, America is not willing to sustain
casualties. In this episode, we'll break
down the system he uses to predict the
future, examine why he's certain America
will lose the war in Iran, and question
if he is a crazy conspiracy theorist or
the only person willing to say the truth
about what's coming next. So, by 2045,
and this is where it gets interesting,
what do you think happens in 2045?
I think
Professor Jean, welcome to the Jack Neil
podcast. Thanks, Jack.
>> Professor Jean, you predicted Trump
would win the 2024 election, America
would invade Venezuela, and most
recently, you predicted the war between
the US and Iran.
Before we understand how you're able to
seemingly predict the future,
why do you think the US will lose the
war with Iran? So I think right now
there are three major vulnerabilities of
the American military and I'll just go
one by one but the first is political
will. The lack of political will meaning
that the American population is not
supportive of this war. Um close to 80%
of Americans
oppose uh a first strike against Iran
and only about 40% of Americans today
still support the military operation
against Iran. Um so that's the first
issue. Second issue is the lack of
manufacturing capacity. So to fight a
modern war, you need to produce a lot of
munitions, uh a lot of missiles, a lot
of tanks. And unfortunately, what
America chose to do was offshore its
manufacturing capacity, its factories to
China. And so that's been a major
constraint on America's capacity to
sustain this war as it drags on. So
that's number two. Number three is that
America is not willing to sustain
casualties
and because it looks bad on TV and
already people are are not supportive of
this war. So if Americans start arriving
back home in body bags then you can
imagine major protests across the
nation. So um these are the three major
constraints on the American military.
What I will do now is explain to you why
each is problematic. Okay. So the first
is the idea of political will and the
and the reason why political will is
important is that in order to win a
modern warfare, you have to move towards
something called total war. Okay. And
what total war is you structure your
entire society
to winning the war. your industry, your
culture, uh your political system all
have to be focused on doing whatever it
takes to winning the war. So last time
America fought a total war was of course
World War II and possibly the Korean
War, but World War II is a classic
example when um the entire American
industrial base shifted from making cars
to making tanks. And that's what you
have to do in order to win because wars
take a long time. They take a lot of
resources. your entire population has to
be behind it. Um, and unfortunately,
Americans grew up watching the Persian
Gulf War, 1991, and then the 2003 Iraq
war. And these were quick, simple wars
that demonstrated America's
technological supremacy. It was like a
video game. And so, the American
population is sort of spoiled. um it's
become indifferent to to war and believe
that okay, you know, it's going to cost
a lot us a lot of money and it's not
moral and it's terrible that these um
civilians overseas are going to die, but
it's not really our problem.
>> So, in other words, I doubt whether or
not the American population is willing
to make the sacrifices necessary in
order to win this war. Is this this
concept of the aura of invincibility
that America has?
>> Right. Okay. So, um the idea of the aura
of invisibility is how America projects
power. Right. So, America doesn't want
want to fight a war. America just wants
to scare people. And so, the way that
America has fought wars these past 20
years is using three pillars. Okay?
These three pillars are aerial
supremacy. So Americans don't send in
ground troops. They just um attack from
the air. And you can't really do regime
change from the air. You have to do it
from the ground. So the way they
compensate for this um is by using
proxies. Right? So you look at the wars
in Libya and Syria where um these rebel
groups, these insurgents were supported
by American air power. Okay, that's
number one. Number two is using
propaganda. So controlling the media
narrative through New York Times,
through the CNN, through social media,
trying to give the illusion that this
war is just, this war can be won really
quickly and there will be no
consequences to this war. And the third
is um the US dollar, which is that the
Americans have the world reserve
currency. Therefore, they can bribe
anyone and everyone to do their bidding.
Right? So you look at the wars in Syria
and Libya where these insurgent groups
were funded by CIA operatives with
endless um like like cash bags, right?
And that and these three pillars give
the illusion of the aura of invability
and invisibility which is America cannot
be defeated. The problem is that it's
just an illusion. It's just theater,
right? So when you run up against an
enemy who doesn't care, who's like I'm
going to fight you to the end because I
don't really believe you and also I'm
not afraid to die and also you're
attacking my home and I'm not going to
just surrender my home to you. Then this
illusion shatters and and that's the
problem in uh Iran right now. And so
when this illusion shatters then you
have to move towards total war which is
okay now I have to commit my resources
to actually winning this war. And
unfortunately, Americans aren't willing
to do that yet, right? So the classic
limits test is gas prices. How much are
Americans willing to pay for gas prices?
And you know, if right now your concern
is gas prices, it probably means you
don't really care about winning this
war, right?
>> Because if this war continues, it's not
just gas prices that are that are the
problem. It's going to be a national
draft. It's going to be economic
collapse. It's going to be um riots in
the streets. It's going to be almost
civil war in America. That's what you
have to do if you actually want to win
win this war. That's how wars are fought
and won in the modern age. Total
commitment, total focus in win this war.
And again, the question is, do the
Americans have political will to fight
and to win this war? And this is a big
question mark. And for America to much
of the political will, you would also
needed to see a radical transformation
in American society
uh from one that's a focus on more uh
liberty individ individual rights to
more authoritarian mechanisms. Um the
the national draft of course is the
classic example. And so um there are
ways that you can muster political will.
Okay. So false flag operations are one
way, right? Okay, so back to World War
II, right? What dragged America into
World War II? Pearl Harbor. Before Pearl
Harbor, most Americans were dead set
against intervening in the wars in
Europe and in in Asia. But Pearl Harbor
changed all that. It's possible that as
this war drags on and more and more
Americans die, then there'll be a surge
of patriotism
um and more Americans will volunteer to
fight this war. It's also possible that
as the economy gets worse and worse, as
people lose their jobs, as the stock
market falters, and people feel a deep
sense of anxiety and desperation, they
believe that it's important to maintain
the empire. Okay, so these are all
possibilities, but you will have to make
this transition in order to sustain this
war. And right now, we're not really
sure if America is willing to make the
sacrifices necessary. Okay, so that's
one big question, political will and you
will need this in order to fight total
war. Okay, so that's the first problem.
Second problem is manufacturing
capacity, right? So again the issue is
that these past 20 years especially um
with the collapse of the Soviet Union
and the coming of the unipolar moment
America has financialized meaning that
um America is the world's hedgeimon and
so every everyone wants to invest in
America because they believe it's the
safest and best place to invest and so
you have all this money coming from the
Middle East from Japan from China from
Russia from Europe and so Wall Wall
Street takes his money and then recycles
it into the American economy and creates
all these risky financial assets called
derivatives um in order to um recycle
all this excess capital, all this
liquidity. This is what led to the 2008
subprime crisis uh when Wall Street
thought that it was invincible. It was
too big to fail. it started to engage in
all the sort of like risky uh behavior
and it collapsed the uh global economy
and it was only kind of easing the
intervention of the Federal Reserve that
saved Wall Street as well as the
American economy. But the problem with
2008 is nothing changed, right? U I I
think that only one mid-level executive
was put in prison and in fact there were
many executives who got bonuses after
they collapsed the um economy. So um we
are still in a period in America where
there's massive financialization where
it seems as though the entire economy is
a Ponzi scheme. And so there are two
major bubbles right now. There's the um
AI data center bubble which is you know
these companies seven of them spending
tons of trillions of dollars and
building building these data centers
creating a product that no one actually
needs or wants. Right? That's the first
problem. Second is the private credit
bubble which is very similar to 2008 um
great financial crisis. So, America is
addicted to finance. Or another way of
saying that is America's addicted to
gambling, right? So, if you're rich, you
put your money in the stock market, but
if you're not rich, if you're young, you
gamble, right? There's all these
gambling sites now that are very popular
that are u accessible.
>> Meme coins as well are a great example
of financialization.
>> It's gambling, right? Cryptocurrency,
gambling markets. it's all this get-rich
um scheme um that's being promoted in in
America. So in order to fight this war,
you can't do that because you need to
move towards manufacturing. You need to
move towards resource um exploration and
exploitation. And America doesn't
Americans don't really want to do the
gritty work anymore, right? So back in
the 50s and 60s, Americans were proud to
be factory workers to to actually create
stuff. And now I think that blue color
work, blue color work, it's sort of like
what illegal immigrants do. It's not
what real Americans do. Um I'm sure
there are lots of Americans who would
love to work in a factory until they
actually work in a factory and recognize
how hard it is. So So that's the second
question. Are Americans willing to
return to the factories and do the um
hard work of build building the
manufacturing sector in order to win
this war? Okay, that's the second big
question. Okay, the third big question
is this uh casualties. Are Americans
willing to die in the Middle East? And
the problem is that again Americans are
don't really know what war is, right?
So, um, you know, if you if you think
about it around the world, if you if you
fight a war, you lose the war, well,
your kids die,
you die, your family dies, your nation
dies, the memory of who you are dies,
war has consequences.
But you know what? These past 40, 50
years, America has fought many wars and
has lost many wars. It lost Vietnam. It
lost um Afghanistan. It lost Iraq. And
the consequence for America is this. You
have these fourstar generals put in
front of Congress where for a couple
hours they're heranged by congressmen
and they feel kind of, you know,
uncomfortable, but that's it, right?
Like there's been real no consequences
for America when America loses a war.
And that is ahistorical. That's not
normal. And unfortunately this time it's
different. If America goes into Iran
with ground troops, if it's committed
for four or five years, if America loses
its war, it means the collapse of
American economy. It means the collapse
of the global economy and it means the
collapse of the petro dollar uh America
the American dollar as a world reserve
currency. It basically means Americans
are now poor.
Okay. And so
>> sorry to stop you.
Does my hair like look flat right now?
It does. Okay. Um, one sec.
Ah, my bad. Yeah, this is my uh friend
Lance's company. It's called Based. Uh,
this is their texture powder, and it's
made with like minerals, all natural
products, and it gives your hair texture
without making it oily or build up on
your scalp. Yeah. I used to use gel or
hairspray, but this actually gives your
hair structure without making it look
like you tried too hard. Yeah. See, it
takes like 30 seconds. It doesn't feel
crunchy. So, if you've been using the
same products for a while without taking
a second look at what's actually in
them, you're probably going to want to
check out Bass Body Works. Based is a
clean plant-based men's grooming brand
that actually performs. Personally, my
favorite product is their texture powder
because it gives you that messy just got
out of bed look, but they also have
shampoo and conditioner, curl cream, and
sea salt spray. So, if you guys want to
check it out, just go to
bassbodyworks.com and use the code
jackneal for 20% off your first order.
And as a bonus, you'll get a free
toiletry bag when you buy your first
set. So, again, that is
bassbodyworks.com
code jackneal or you can scan the QR
code on screen because confidence
shouldn't come at the cost of your
health. But anyway, guys, back to the
podcast. So, these are three big
questions. Uh, one is, is the nation
able to unify?
um politically around the idea of
winning this war in the Middle East to
believe that it is a cause worth dying
for. Second question is, is America
willing to transition its economy from
financialization back to manufacturing,
which which would actually mean radical
social transformation.
>> And the third big question is how much
sacrifice are Americans willing to make
in this war? Are they willing to die in
the Middle East? Okay. And again, these
are three big questions. And given what
I've seen, given past behavior, I think
it'd be very hard for Americans to make
this transition on the manufacturing. I
just want to clarify that. Are you
saying like u military like firearms, uh
tanks, that type of manufacturing or you
just mean general manufacturing as a
whole?
>> Let's put it very simply. Okay. You need
drones to win this war.
>> Okay. Why? Because right now you have
asymmetry going on. We just say the
economics of war don't make any sense
right now. America because of the
military-industrial complex. It's put
billions of dollars into this expensive
air defense network. Right? So you've
got the FAT system um thermal high
altitude air defense. You've got the
Patriot systems. And the military
industrial complex it's not designed to
win wars. It's designed to transfer
taxpayer money to a transnational elite,
right? It's it it's meant to line the
pockets of the national security
apparatus, the the deep state.
>> And so they build these expensive
weapons and they look really fancy and
they're really impressive, but they've
never been tested in war.
>> Okay. So now we're seeing what these
systems look like in war. And it's been
an embarrassment for America because
you've got these aircraft carriers, the
Gerald Art Ford nuclearpowered aircraft
carrier, the most advanced in the world,
$13 billion price tag. It's done nothing
in this war. In fact, it sort of ran
away from the theater because of this
laundry fire. And people are speculating
that it's not really laundry fire. It
was like they were hit by a drone or a
blissing missile. So the Iranians have
proven that they can actually attack and
sabotage these in supposedly invincible
war machines. So 13 billion dollars zero
forward and it's afraid to fight. Okay,
that's that's number one. Number two is
you've got these um most advanced
airplanes, the F-35, the most advanced
in the world, cost $100 million each.
Took 26 years to fully develop
it. You can't It's supposed to be
stealth. You can't see it. The Iranians
shot one. It was forced to make an
emergency landing. What did they shoot
it with? Um, we're not sure, but um, it
was it was probably a a a missile of
some sort. So, meaning that the Iranians
were able to with their low technology
radar lock onto an F-35, the heat
signature and launch a missile added.
And and also, I mean, like, let's be
realistic. These are very complex
machines that are being asked to um
fight a war of attrition, meaning they
they're going in every single day for a
long time. And when you have this, you
know, very very expensive technology,
eventually you're going to have
maintenance issues. So these machines
were not designed to fight a long war.
They were meant to do like a at most
twoe war. Okay. So So it's showing the
wear and tear of the American military
mission. Okay? So that's the F-35. And
then you have the Patriot systems. And
unfortunately, if you look at what's
happening in the Middle East and in
Israel, there's a lot of leakage. Okay?
These things are billion billion dollar
um machines and they're supposed to
defend your um your air, but these cheap
um Iranian drones are getting through.
So, let's go back to the economics. The
right now a Patriot missile to shoot one
Patriot missile in the air cost about a
million dollars.
The Iranians used the Shihad drones
which cost anywhere for between 20,000
to 50,000. you will need about two to
three Patriot missiles to shoot down one
of these drones. So, the economics
doesn't make any sense for you to uh win
this war. You have to shift the
economics to make it much more
sustainable. And that basically means
mass manufacturing drones. That also
means unfortunately ground troops,
right? Because the problem with air
defense is it defense against air. So,
it is silly for America to send in these
advanced fighter jets into Iran against
their air defense systems. It doesn't
matter even how low tech their air
defense is. Eventually, they're going to
shoot down some planes and they have
shot down two planes uh already. Um
yesterday, uh it was reported they shot
down an F-15 and now they're looking for
the the pilot. The way you counter air
defense is you use ground troops, use
infantry to clear the air defense so
that your um so you can establish aerial
supremacy. But it's almost impossible to
establish aerosmreacy against an
opponent without ground forces. Okay. So
um if America is to win this war, it
needs ground forces and it needs to have
factories mass-produce drones as much as
Iran is uh producing drones. So so look
at the war in Ukraine. If you just go to
the front lines, it's just all fiber
optics, right? I mean, you go these
villages, it's like webs of fiber
optics. Why? Because um the drones are
have fiber optics attached to avoid
jamming,
>> right?
>> So, so that's what modern warfare looks
like. And and so you need to mass
manufacture drones. Right now, Iran can
can manufacture about 500 drones a day.
America needs to produce about 1,000 to
stay competitive. Why is Iran a perfect
example of asymmetric warfare? And can
you define asymmetric warfare just
simply? Asymmetric warfare means that
the opponent um does not fight you on
equal terms. The opponent is fighting
you asymmetrically and using fewer
resources to accomplish more strategic
objectives. Okay. So um in the cold war
it was semical warfare between the
Soviet Union and America because you're
competing um with the same metrics. So
for example um how many how many nuclear
weapons did you have? Did you have
access to hydro hydrogen weapons? Um how
many tanks did you have? How many
infantry did you have? Okay. So these
were the metrics we used to judge the
cold war because uh America and the
Soviet Union were symmetrical opponents.
>> Asymmetry happens when you fight when
when when the when the opposing sides
are not equal in terms of economics,
demographics
and uh geography. So in the Iranian
situation, the Iranians had at least 20
years to prepare for today. Okay. Okay.
So, you're an Iranian strategist and you
saw what happened in 1991, the Persian
Gulf War. You saw what happened in 2003
um operation um Iraqi um freedom. And
you know how the Americans fight?
Americans fight using aerosmreacy. They
come in, it's shocking all they blow
everything up. The ground forces come in
and sweep everything up. Okay? So, you
know it's fast. You know it's deadly.
But you also know it's expensive. You
can also make the assumption that
Americans don't like to fight a war of
attrition because then it becomes
politically unviable. Okay. So, so if
you're an Iranian strategist, what you
recognize is that to beat the Americans,
you can't fight on American terms. You
can't use advanced weapons. You can't go
headto-head. You don't want to mash your
forces. So, what you do is you hide
yourself in the Zagos mountains.
you you prepare for a long war. I'm
talking like 10 years, possibly 20
years, right? You decentralize your
forces. The Iranians use something
called the Mosiaak defense, which is say
like it's almost like a spider's web
where each part, each node is
responsible for its own local defense.
And if any part breaks down, the
surrounding areas come in to um fill out
their their defense. But it's
decentralized meaning that the American
strategy of shock and all decapitation
strikes don't really work. Uh because
system system is much more resilient,
much more fluid than Americans are used
to, right? And you try to inflict not
military damage because the Americans
can withstand that. What you do is you
attack economic
um uh choke holds. for example humus for
example the oil fields of the um Middle
East right so that's that's the idea of
asymmetrical warfare and the other point
I wanted to touch on is you said that it
would be hard to rally American
sentiment like a 24-year-old kid like me
to want to enlist and go fight an
American war in Iran if you had to guess
what kind of event would happen that
would actually rally sentiment of I
don't know Gen Z uh people under 35
people eligible for the draft. What kind
of event would that be?
>> My best guess is it's very hard to
create an event that rallies Gen Z,
>> right?
>> But there is a solution because the idea
of fighting this war is you need ground
troops to soak up the air defense. you
need ground troops to soak up the
artillery and the drones, right? This is
the economics of war, meaning you're
trying to win this war um more
efficiently than your opponent, right?
So, if they are like if they have like
$50,000 Shahit drones, then you need you
need a resource a weapon that's cheaper
than that. Okay? So, it's possible to
use drones, but you also need ground
forces. And so where can you recruit
um expandable ground forces and it's
going to be illegal im immigrants,
right? So the idea that you're going to
have a national draft and all these Gen
Z kids who have pretty comfortable lives
compared with their parents' generation,
right? Um and they're going to go off to
a desert, a m a mountain fortress, and
they're going to go and die and be
basically cannon fodder. That to me
sounds a bit absurd. But what you can do
is you can organize a national draft and
then have so much political um uh
fervor. People are pro protesting so
much because quite honestly Jenzi would
rather go to prison than go to Iran I
would think. Right. But then what you
can do is you can trans transition and
say fine let's do a compromise.
Let's have the illegal immigrants do
this. Right. So, it's your choice. You
can either go back to um um Latin
America or you can go to Iran and win
citizenship for your family. Not just
for you, but your immediate family, your
children, your your your parents, your
wife. And quite honestly, I hate to say
this, but for a lot of illegal
immigrants, this is actually a pretty
attractive offer.
Um, so if I had to guess, I think they
will try false flags and I think they
will have national draft and I think
this will not work out and so they'll
get desperate and they'll start to
recruit illegal immigrants to fight this
war. And what state has the highest
number of illegal immigrants?
>> Yeah, I'm not actually sure.
>> Yeah, I was just I was trying to guess
where an event might happen. that
logic's out and it seems like sentiment
is definitely anti- illegal immigration
at least in the US.
>> I'll also say that there's there's going
to be another false flag that people
don't anticipate which is an attack on
America's
financial infrastructure. Okay, so the
data centers that undergur
the um banking system, right? So you
have a bank bank account, right? And
it's all stored on a server somewhere.
What happens if that server gets blown
up? money is gone. Then your money is
gone, right? And so I point this out
because um America has a huge problem
which is there's too much liquidity in
the system.
And so if you're trying to run a
financial system, you can't have that
because if you if there's too much
liquidity, no one actually works, right?
Right? If you got a million dollar
sitting in a bank, you're like, "Okay, I
could just sit at home and gamble with
it or do Only Fans or I could go to work
from 9 to5, put up with with a
boss, do work that is meaningless and
get paid nothing for it." Right? So, you
have the situation where no one's no one
no one wants to work anymore. So, the
only solution to that is you just
destroy the um banking system. You you
burn out people's cash. So now they're
forced to work. You got these boomers
who sit sit these boomers might have
like $3 million in the bank account and
then and then much more in stock market,
right? And then much more in real
estate. And so they they can just
support their kids and their grandkids.
You can't have that, right? If you're
going to transition back to a
manufacturing economy. Based on what
you've said, I think it would be
unreasonable to say that Trump's ego is
so large that he thinks he would win
this war.
Do you think Trump is trying to lose the
war in Iran on purpose? So, um, that's a
really good question and I think it's a
very complicated question. So, I I I
want to break it down into parts. Okay.
>> So, the first part I I I want to look at
is what goes on in Trump's head. What
motivates him? And he is a reality TV
star. He um he spent all of his life in
the tabloids,
right? And being a tabloid means that
you're just constantly curating,
manufacturing your image in the public.
So, uh, in the ' 80s, his image was that
of a billion billionaire playboy, right?
So, he's always with like these, uh,
beautiful models. But the thing that
people don't recognize about Donald
Trump is he's very, very strategic and
he's very manipulative and he's very
deliberate in everything he does. And
so, I I'll give you an example of that,
okay? I didn't know this until
um I think two years ago, but I just
found out that Donald Trump does not
drink. He's never drunk. He refuses to
touch alcohol. And that's kind of
dissonance, right? Because you imagine
while you're building a playboy and you
you host like the most lavish parties in
New York, you are dating supermodels and
you are hanging out with um
the celebrities. So you don't drink. So
So picture this where you know like like
it's a ballroom. You got a thousand of
the most beautiful, wealthiest people in
America and they're getting drunk and
they're doing drugs in the bathroom. And
Donald Trump, he's the host. He's going
around and he's shaking hands,
conversing with people, taking pictures,
but he's not drinking. What kind of man
does that? Why would he do that? So, my
only interpretation is that Donald
Trump, he's deliberate, okay? He's been
planning this for a long time. If you go
back to the late 80s, early 90s, and
like this guy's going to like this
Republican National Convention,
Democratic National Convention, he's
talking to CNN. He's saying like, you
know what, I should run for president
and if I if I ran, I would win.
>> Okay. So, so people don't really
appreciate this about Donald Trump.
Right? So, that's the first point I
make. Second point I would make is Evan
thinks Donald Trump is in the Epstein
files. But my question is this. If he
were in the Epstein files, wouldn't Joe
Biden and his attorney general, Marlik
Garland, wouldn't they have exposed this
during the four years they were in
office when they had access to all the
Epson files?
>> And people also forget that Donald Trump
is hated by the elite. He was hated by
Jeffrey Epstein.
Why? Because he didn't play by the
rules. He wasn't part of the club,
right? So, you look at all these people
who were flying to Epstein Island, Bill
Clinton, Bill Gates, Larry Summers,
um Steven Pinker, okay? Just the most
elite in politics, in finance, and in u
academia. And Donald Trump, he maybe he
did go, but he wasn't part of that club,
right? So, Donald Trump was an outsider
for most of his life. Like look, if you
go back to the 80s and you were to
survey like the most powerful man in uh
New York City, okay, the people actually
ran New York City, they would every one
of them would say, "Donald Trump, this
guy's a clown.
He's a clown. He's stupid. He's useless.
He's bankrupt. It's just his dad's
money." Okay? He's playing with his
dad's money. So, Donald Trump has always
been an outsider. He's always felt
persecuted.
So I would I would just um put
everything together. Okay, this guy has
been planning something since the 80s.
He's very deliberate. He's very
disciplined.
He's not part of the elite the way the
way that it's traditionally understood.
If if if he were, he'd be best friends
with with with like the Clintons and the
Obamas and no one would oppose him in
2016 when when he became president.
People forget that in 2016 when he was
president and he had this inauguration,
no one went because like no one wanted
to be associated with this guy even
though he was president president of the
United States and the media mocked him
every single day. And people forget this
but in 2016 the big thing was Russia
gate where Donald Trump was clearly an
agent of Russia. Putin had blackmail on
him and um Putin put him in office and
and and that was the idea of Russia gate
and that was something that the media
the mainstream media promoted every
single day and it turned out to be a
nothing burger because Robert Mueller
did a investigation and if you just look
looked at Muller report he just said it
very clearly in the report there's no
evidence at all linking
Donald Trump
and his family to Vladimir Putin. And I
would say the same same about Jeffrey
Epstein where I'm sure that Mara Garland
had a huge team looking for anything
that could incriminate Donald Trump.
There was nothing in the Epstein files.
So this is a guy who associates with
like the most perverted, the sleest
people on the planet Earth, but he
himself is not implicated in whatever
they do. That's really strange.
All right. So, all I'm saying is that I
think Donald Trump is much more
deliberate, much more methodical, uh
much more strategic than people give him
credit for. The issue though is
what does he want? Okay, so that's the
second part of the question. What does
he really want? And
Americans are Americans think that, you
know, Donald Trump, he's corrupt. He
wants to be the richest man in America.
And that doesn't really hold water
because
um if he wants to be the richest man in
America, why is he pissing everyone off
like this, right? Why doesn't he just
sell himself out to these societies,
these uh billionaires? Why antagonize
them the way he's done, right? With in
2016, he was like, you know, like, let's
kick out these illegal immigrants. Let's
not go go fighting more wars. Uh these
billionaires have been stealing from the
country all their lives. like why
antagonize the powerful like this,
right? So, the idea that Donald Trump is
only interested in money doesn't really
hold water. So, um here's my theory of
Donald Trump and again um let me know if
you have any questions. Okay.
>> Right. But
he believes
in his heart
he is on a mission from God to save
America.
That's literally what he believes. He
believes every day
when he's alone in the bedroom doing
Twitter or watching Fox News, God is
whispering in his ear. He feels he has a
divine connection
to God that no one else does.
He feels that he's almost like Jesus
where he's on a secret messianic mission
that only he understands but no one else
does. But that's the curse
that he has to suffer in order to save
America. That's what he believes. All
right. And then the question then is
what's his mission then?
If you just look at his rhetoric, if you
look at his actions, he has certain
worldview, which is that America has
been co-opted and corrupted by the
transnational
financial elite,
Wall Street, the city of London,
um, Bank of England, okay, Bank of
Sentiments, okay, just the transnational
capital.
And as a result, America has lost its
purity. America fought a revolution to
get rid of these guys, right? And now
they're back and they control the
Federal Reserve. They control the milit
military-industrial complex. They
control the deep state. It's all the
same people really. And so America is
forced into these wars overseas. America
is forced to allow illegal immigration
which dilutes the purity, the heritage,
the culture of America without without
identity, without culture, without
history. Who are you? What are you?
Right? Um, uh, it's these people that
promote DEI, that promote world
politics, which intentionally
brainwashes, indoctrinates young people
into believing the most absurd things
about themselves and the world, which
reduces the capacity of American men to
be strong, to be masculine.
>> Um, and so that's what he believes.
And so then the question then is okay if
you believe this
and you believe that only you can save
America,
how do you do so? Well, in his first
term, he started himself with generals.
He started himself with people who knew
Washington DC well and he played by the
rules. And what happened? They cheated
him, right? 2020 he won that election
fair and square. The American people
supported everything he did. He he
worked hard for America and his entire
cabinet betrayed him.
The deep state spent $6 billion to rig
that election to steal it from him.
And then and then they staged January 6
which was a protest
uh Ghana mock but they called an
interaction and they impeached him and
they and they tried to put him in jail
or at the very least prevent him from
ever
um standing for re-election again. They
tried to destroy him. Then after he goes
home to Mara Lago, they raided his home
for what exactly? for having
confidential uh information. Listen, in
Washington DC, everything is
confidential. If I give you a piece of
paper that has my name on it, it's
confidential, right? And you take it
home. Well, well, now you have a state
secret sitting in your garage. Joe Biden
had state secrets in his garage in
Delaware. Okay. Hillary Clinton had her
own private email server. There was no
raid, FBI raid on on their homes. Then
you have lawfare against Donald Trump.
You had like lawsuit after lawsuit. They
try to bankrupt him. They try to put him
in put him in jail. And so Donald Trump
recognized that the strategy of trying
to work with the deep state.
The strategy of trying to confront these
guys head on, that's not going to work.
So in the second term, he's he's changed
his tact. Okay. His strategy is now I'm
going to give these guys all that they
want.
I'm going to do exactly what they tell
me to do. Right?
And so what the strategy here is
actually interesting
because um in China
um there's a strategy that managers use
to destroy people who threaten them and
it's called pang sha in Chinese but the
idea of this is you flatter someone to
death right so so in the Greek um world
the worst thing is the idea of hubris so
the gods who the gods want to destroy
they first make proud
Right? And what that means is you put
your enemies on a pedestal. You give
them whatever they want. You shine a
spotlight on them. And then
first of all, whatever happens is going
to blow up in their face, but also they
get all the blame for it. Whereas before
in the first term, it was Donald Trump
that got all the blame for everything
that happened.
>> Right? So I will give an example.
Everyone thinks that Jared Kushner is
the puppet master, right? He's the one
who is manipulating things behind the
scenes. He's the one who's actually uh
controlling Middle East policy in
America. And the evidence is he goes to
Ukraine, negotiate negotiates with Putin
on a peace deal.
Um he goes to Gaza
to negotiate the peace deal there. He
creates support of peace
and he goes to Iran to negotiate a peace
deal.
Why is this guy who's not even a
government employee involved in the most
highstakes political negotiations for
America? Him and his buddy Steve Woff,
right? And so Evan just says, "Well,
Jared Kushner is the one who's
controlling Donald Trump." But let me
ask you this question.
If you were the true puppet master, will
you put yourself on stage? Would you
have that spotlight shone on you so that
if something goes wrong, everyone blames
you?
Everyone now thinks if this war in Iran
goes sideways, it's Jared Kushner's
fault.
If this war in Ukraine
um explodes,
it's Jared Kushner's fault. If things
don't work out in Israel, it's Jared
Kushner's fault. It was never Donald
Trump. It was Jared Kushner. And so
that's what Donald Trump is doing this
term. He is letting his enemies
get on stage and make complete jackasses
of themselves. Right? So, but you're
like, "Wait, um Jared Kushner is Trump's
son-in-law. They're not enemies. Yes,
they are. If you know Donald Trump's
personality, he values one thing and one
thing only, loyalty.
Jerkin is not loyal to Donald Trump. And
we know because after January 6 when
everyone was distancing himself or
herself from Donald Trump, Jerus
disappeared. Okay, just go back to that
time when Trump's cabinet was quitting
on him when the Republicans were calling
for his impeachment.
Jared Kushner and Rean Trump who made a
lot of money in Trump's first term, they
disappeared because they didn't want to
lose their friends. They don't they
didn't want to be associated with the
dumps of fire that was Donald Trump.
Do you think that Donald Trump might
have a grudge against Jar Kushner?
>> That would make sense to me.
>> I would think so. And do you think
Donald Trump is a guy to like just go?
Do you think that he's like, hm, well,
you know, yeah, he betrayed me, but at
the same time, he's still my son-in-law,
and you know, he's a father of my
grandchildren, and he's a husband to my
uh favorite daughter, Ivanka.
No, he's like, screw this guy. First of
all, he stole my daughter from me.
Second of all, he made her convert to
Judaism. What is that crap?
And third of all, when I needed him the
most, he ran away. Yeah, it's really
hard to keep track of where all of your
money is going. Like, have you ever
thought about how many different
software subscriptions you're using to
run your business or social media
channels? Because if you're like me,
you're probably doing email marketing on
one platform, you're running your
website on another platform, customer
support/CRM somewhere else, and you're
spending thousands of dollars a month on
all these tools, and you barely can keep
track of all of it. That's why I was so
glad our team started using Highle. It's
basically the operating system for our
entire business, all in one place. Now,
be honest with me. Are you currently
paying more than $97 a month to keep
track of your leads in a CRM? send
automated emails and text messages,
build landing pages, and process
payments. If you said yes, you're
probably going to want to switch to High
Level. So, seriously, if you want to
stop paying for eight different software
subscriptions to run your business, just
go to jackneil.com/highle
or scan the QR code on screen. Again,
that is jackneil.com/hyle
if you want to run your entire business
with one platform.
But anyway, guys, back to the podcast.
So Jared Kushner comes back from exile
and now he is the most high-profile
member of Trump's team in the Middle
East. Do you think that's a good thing
for him or a bad thing for him?
>> I think he thinks it's a good thing for
him.
>> He does. But that's why Trump is so good
because he gives you what you want,
right? If you love someone, you want to
protect that person. You want to do
what's right for that person. You don't
give that person whatever he or she
wants. I have this um child, my my boy,
he's like four. Every day he's saying to
me, "I want candy. If you don't give me
candy, I I hate you. You don't love me."
And I'm like, "Okay, I don't love you
then."
Right?
I will say uh just to close a loop that
people might be thinking about is
I don't think the average individual
like is thinking that Jared Kushner is
making all the decisions, but I think
that the most important people in DC and
the most important people in the media
assume that to be true. So, the second
order effects if something does go bad
in Iran would be that uh the media will
put the blame on Kushner and people, the
average American will start to put the
pieces together there. Um I don't think
they'll just be like, "Oh, it was
Trump's fault." Uh because the media
will feed them that it was Jared
Kushner. Is that right?
>> Right. So, um that's part of it. Okay.
But the thing about Donald Trump is he
is a real reality TV star. So, he's
thinking in terms of like plot lines and
narrative. Okay. So, what's happening is
that Donald Trump has betrayed MAGA
because the first thing that he's
promised MAGA is no more wars,
>> right? So he started this war unprovoked
against Iran
and this is seen as a betrayal and
that's why so many influential um MAGA
people such as Tucker Carlson um have
come out and opposed this war because
it's a betrayal of all that MAGA stands
for which is America first. So what so
he's doing this again to put his enemies
on a pedestal to give them what they
want to collapse the military-industrial
complex in the financial sector who are
his enemies really of from the first
term right but he also has to think
ahead and say how do I redeem myself in
the eyes of MAGA how do I get out of
this dumpster fire right what's my
offramp
and so at some point at when it's clear
that this war is just a complete
dumpster fire and he needs to bail.
Okay, he's going to bail because he
because he's not invested in this war.
He's got no ego in this thing,
>> right? His job is to get a third term so
that he can save America. And whether or
not America wins this war, loses this
war, he doesn't really care. It's it's
it's not a factor in his calculations.
But he needs to figure out how to
create an off. Okay? So ask yourself
this question.
Why is Tulsi Gabbard in his cabinet?
Why is she director of national
intelligence? Where did she come from?
She's a Democrat. And like
why would she be given such a powerful
position in Washington DC? The reason
why is everyone associates her with
anti-war. Everyone associates her with
anti- military-industrial complex.
Right? So in other words,
um, Donald Trump came into his second
term creating two camps. You have the
anti-war camp, JD Vance and Kelsey
Gabbard, and you have like the pro-war
people,
uh, Marco Rubio, um, Jared Kushner, um,
Peter Hexiff, right? These guys. So it's
clear that there's this m that's
division in the White House. So why
would Trump do that? Because Trump is
trying to create a um narrative where at
first he was bamboozled by
Marco Rubio and Peter Hv and Jared
Kushner and Steve Woff, but then
JD Vance, Tulsi Gabbard,
they
pray to God or whatever, you know, and
he saw he saw the light and then he
joined JD Vans and Tel Gabard imposing
this war.
>> Okay. And that's his offer.
And then
JD Vans and Taigy Gapird will say to
Magga, we have to forgive him because
he's our only hope to stop this war.
Before we get into some of your other
predictions, I want to understand how
you make them. Uh
what would you say is the most important
framework you use for evaluating the
past, present, and the future? like how
do you predict the future? Sure. So in
my um predictive model there are three
pillars. Okay. The most important is
game theory. Second is historical
patterns. The third is estology. So I'll
explain one one by one. Okay. Game
theory. Okay.
So
game theory. I used to play a lot of
poker. Texas hold poker
and
when I'm playing poker it's usually
tournament poker so I have a lot of time
to kill so I spend a lot of time just
analyzing the metag game okay like like
who are these people why are they doing
what they're doing and what I discovered
playing poker is that
there are no dumb players in the game
they're all rational but they have their
own different perspective on how the
game should be played So the world view
drives their strategy which drives their
action.
And if you spend enough time just
analyzing a player, you can figure out
the person's entire strategy. Um and
then I recognized that okay well we can
apply this metaphor to geopolitics which
is say that each nation state has its
own particular worldview as determined
by its culture, its history, its
political system and then it's going to
take this worldview and develop a
strategy for how to navigate the world.
And sometimes these worldviews will come
into conflict with each other. And so
once you start to recognize
that the world is not set by a universal
um standard,
but rather that the world is flexible
and dynamic and open and that each
player um is participating in a zero sum
game and trying to optimize his or her
advantage in this game,
then the world makes a lot more sense.
Um, but the problem with this is to do
game theory properly, you would need
perfect information, right? So, go back
to the poker table analogy where if I'm
able to see everyone's cards, right? If
I'm able to see everyone's minds, then I
can predict exactly how they how they
behave, right? Um, but you don't have
that perfect perfect information. You
can only make um guesses. And it's and
it's even and this is even more true in
geopolitics because you don't have
access to the nation's
top minds. You don't know you don't know
who the leaders are. You don't
understand how the political system
works. You don't understand this
dynamic. So it's very hard for you to
gauge their behavior. So what what I do
next then is fine, I don't have this
perfect information. In fact, I don't
have most of this information, but am I
able to go back in history and look at
events that are similar to today and
then am I able to draw analogies between
the past and the present
and this will help me. Okay. And the
third thing I will look at is that of
esquetology. Okay. And esquetology
um do you want me to explain what
esquetology is or
>> 100%. Okay. Sure. Okay.
Esquetology comes from the Greek word
escaton which means the end. So
literally it means the study of the end.
What it means is um that each religion
has its own understanding
and theory
of how the world ends or how we become
reunited with God.
And um esquetology
is often
connected with the most extreme
religious elements. And the reason why
is that esquetology is very compelling.
It's like a movie script. And it's as
though people want to act it out because
if you see the ending, right? If you if
you know that Jesus can return if you
act out certain things for certain
things if certain things were to line up
together. If they were to align then
Jesus would return then that makes you
much more determined and motivated to
actually fulfill
this prophecy.
>> Right? Right? So the prophecy becomes a
plan and that's the and why esquetology
is important is that people who do
believe in in this esquetology are much
more motivated than others, much more
energetic, much more cohesive than
others, which means that they have more
power than other people. And so they are
the players to watch out for in this
game. And so if you look at what's
happening in the Middle East, you can
make the argument that a lot of it is
driven by esquetology in that you have
these Christian Zionists, you have these
religious Jews who believe that by
manipulating certain events in Middle
East by provoking a war there.
Basically, you will usher in the end
times.
Um you you for Christian Zionist, it
means the rapture and the return of
Jesus. For religious Jews, it means the
coming of the Messiah and the building
of the of the third temple and the
coming of the messianic age. Okay? But
also what people don't appreciate is
that not only is esquetology a prophecy
in the plan, but it's also a hidden
history. And the reason why is that
we don't have much written history.
maybe since the Greeks, okay? But the
Greeks go back, you know, 3,000 years.
So, so it's not that much. We've been
around for at least 10,000 years. You go
back to go playepe in the Ice Age cave
paintings. Okay? So, we go back a long
time. We don't have that history. In
fact, we don't have most of our history.
So, what religion does is that religion
takes the broad history and allegorizes
it into narratives, into stories, into
religious beliefs that capture the
essence of this history. So if we
believe that history repeats itself or
there's a certain pattern to history,
what religion is is it deciphers for you
or reveals to you these patterns of
history. So think of a astrology, right?
Astrology is trying to reveal to you the
patterns of the stars, the movement of
the stars which then determines
um how events unfold in the real world,
right? Well, escology is very similar to
a astrology in this way in that
esquetology is not just a plan. It's
it's not just a prophecy, but it's also
a hidden framework of how events will
turn out, right? And if you look at
esquetology, it's mainly about the
decline of empire, the decline of
civilization.
And this has happened a lot in human
history. And if you look at what's
happening today from a historical
perspective, it is the decline of
empire, the decline of civilization.
It's almost like the bronze age
collapse. And so esquetology provides
you with a with a pretty good framework
of how this thing will unfold. Can you I
think the esquetology portion is where a
lot of people tune out of your work.
They think conspiracy theorist uh this
guy like this doesn't make any sense
that people would act in a certain way
based on the end times. Can you give me
like a really simple example of how if
you and I shared an esquetology it would
lead to our decisions in life being
different? Like can you give an example
of this?
>> Sure. Okay. So let's look at the mo the
most um dominant esquetologies. Okay. So
you have first start with the uh Jewish
esquetology
and the Jews believe that
um they are the chosen people and they
are God's the Yahweh's favorite people
and um the highlight or the apex of
their civilization was King David's
kingdom the Davidic kingdom uh and um
King Solomon. Okay. And this was when
King Solomon built Solomon's temple,
which was a house of God. And this was
where Yahweh lived to be with his
people. But unfortunately, the Jewish
people were not loyal. They were
unfaithful. So they started to marry
foreign women, which brought in foreign
gods. And then Yahweh became
annoyed um angry at the infidelity of
the Jews. So he left and that and this
allowed uh invaders such as the
Babylonians and the Assyrians to conquer
um Jerusalem.
And eventually this led to the Jewish
diaspora, the scattering of the Jews.
But even in even diaspora, they long to
return to Jerusalem to be reunited with
their God. And in the Jewish tradition,
what the rabbis tell the Jewish people
is when God is ready, when the Jewish
people are ready for this reunion, the
Messiah will come. The Messiah will lead
the Jewish people back to the promised
land. He will um build the nation of
Israel and he will return. He will
summon the diaspora to return to Israel
and he will build the third temple so
that God will come eventually he will
face um his enemies in the war of Gog
but he will triumph and this will usher
in the messianic age. So as Jewish
people, our main responsibility is to
reflect deeply on who we are, engage in
spiritual alchemy, and once we engage in
a long process of redemption,
and we once our hearts open up to God,
then God will send us Messiah. So be a
good person and wait and be patient.
Okay? So So that's the standard
mainstream Jewish understanding.
But then you have these extremists
who
believe that is not God's intention.
God's intention is for the Jews to prove
that they love God and they
will they desire reunion with God. And
so it must be the Jews to act out first
before God sends his Messiah. And that
means you must first resurrect
reconstitute the nation of Israel.
You must build the third temple. You
must fight the war of Gog and Magog. And
when the Jews have done all they can,
but the entire world seems to have
united against Jews because that's the
world that that's what the world does
actually, unite against Jews. And when
God sees that his people are in most
desperate need, but he sees that his
people
have redeemed themselves, have repented
and yearn for re of God, then God will
intervene and set the world right. And
that is when the messianic age will
occur. But you must first make the
sacrifice necessary in order to to
welcome the Messiah and the coming of of
Yahweh. Okay? So you can see how in the
first iteration,
yeah, it's interesting, but in the
second iteration, there's sort of a
passion, an energy, an excitement to it
where it's just like, wow, there's this
grand historical script being played
out. It's all part of God's divine plan.
And I can play my part in achieving this
divine plan. So why shouldn't I? If I'm
truly faithful, if I'm tr if I truly
believe in God,
if I want to prove myself worthy,
shouldn't I do my part to achieve this
plan? Okay. So, does a Jewish
esquetology make sense to you? Yeah,
that definitely makes sense. And I do
want to clarify for people that you're
not saying that these uh esquetologies
are necessarily real. You're saying that
this is what the people believe. So, it
changes the way that they act. And
that's how you use it to predict the
future. Do you think it's important for
people to understand the law of uh
esquetological convergence to understand
how you predict the future?
>> Sure. Sure. Okay.
>> Hey, really quick. Do you have a 401k, a
Roth IRA, or happen to have a lot of
money in crypto? Because you're
definitely going to want to hear about
this. See, the biggest supporters of
this podcast right now are the guys over
at iTrust Capital. And when they first
reached out to me and explained what
they did, it literally sounded like a
cheat code. See, with their platform,
you can convert your existing 401k or
Roth IRA into one that lets you buy
Bitcoin, Ethereum, and over 80
cryptocurrencies while maintaining the
same tax-saving benefits. Now, of
course, you can start a new IRA with
them if you're bullish on Bitcoin and
want to save on taxes if you ever decide
to cash out. But if you're someone who
already has a lot of crypto and you're
worried about it getting hacked or
stolen, iTrust also offers a PCA
account, which is institutionalgrade
level custody, meaning your assets are
fully insured, ultra secure, and never
sitting on any risky exchanges. So, if
you guys want to get access, just go to
jacknil.com/iritrust
or scan the QR code on screen. Again,
that is jackneil.com/itrust
or hit the first link in the description
for an easy $100 bonus.
But anyway, back to the podcast. So, um,
there are different there's the
different esquetologies. Okay, so I just
mentioned the Jewish esquetology, but
there are others. There's an Orthodox
esquetology, there's the Catholic one,
there's the um Protestant one, the
Christian Zionist one, uh, there's the
Mormon one, okay? There's a Freemason
one. So, there are all these different
esquetologies out there. And what you
what's really interesting is at certain
points they converge together meaning
they align at certain points meaning
that these are different religious
traditions
again we're talking only about a
minority these extremists right maybe at
1% of the entire uh cohort okay but
these are the most energetic they're the
most unified they're the most determined
right and if they're working together to
achieve a certain script and if the
script is similar similar at certain
points that you can be certain or
confident that these things will turn
out because at the end of the day
we're the players in this grand
historical narrative. So what what we do
is what determines the history. Um so if
you just look at certain convergence
points it's amazing how they align.
Okay. So one major convergence point is
the reconstitution of the nation of
Israel. This happened in 1948.
Then another convergence point is war
and chaos in the Middle East which is
happening right now. Another convergence
point is the building of the third
temple. And this is this is problematic
because right now the Alex mosque which
is the third holiest site in the Muslim
world, it actually sits on where the
third temple should be. And so you need
to destroy the third holiest site in the
second world in order to build your
third temple.
>> Is that in Jerusalem?
>> It is. It's all in Jerusalem. Yes. Yes.
Um and so um it if the Alex mosque would
be destroyed, this would trigger a
religious war. But again, if these
esquetologies
um are really powerful and true, they
all agree there will be a religious war
in the Middle East,
>> which will lead eventually to the war of
Gawk and Magog, which is also what they
agree on. They also agree, this is
really interesting, is that America will
will not be part of this narrative,
right? America does not participate in
the Middle East. So in other words, what
they what they all believe is that
America will lose this war against Iran
and retreat back to North America and be
engulfed in the civil war.
That's what they all believe.
Um they also believe that um China will
not participate in the Middle East
affairs and and China will probably
retreat also into its own borders and
turtle up. Um yeah. Yeah. So, you have
this convergence and that's how how I'm
able to make these predictions because
well, you know, if they want to behave
in this way and they're powerful people,
well, they'll probably succeed. You made
a series of predictions and I have some
dates here. What's your prediction for
2027?
>> Sure. Okay. So, let's look at some major
events that are happening right now.
Okay. So, you've got this war in Iran
that seems to be escalating day by day.
Um, you have the midterms coming up in
November and people expect the Democrats
to sweep the House in which case they
will probably impeach Donald Trump.
And you also have
basically global economic collapse
because the Iranians have um closed the
street of humus
and so fertilizer and oil LNG are not
able to be transported around the world.
um 20 um so the uh Middle East provides
about 20% of the world the world's oil
supply um and it's also high quality um
that the rest of the world can actually
replicate.
Um, so these are all very pressing
issues right now, right? So my
prediction for how things will unfold
is that number one, I think this war
between United States and Iran will only
escalate. There can be no offramp
because first of all, Donald Trump sees
this war in Iran as crucial in achieving
his meatic mission which we talked about
earlier.
the military-industrial complex,
Pentagon, the military, once they get
into a war, they don't back out. You
know, they're what I mean, it's
I mean, it's human nature, right? Where
it's some cost fallacy where you've
already invested so much into this war
and you're not going to say, you know
what, I've lost enough. I'm going to go
home, right? Is is going to casino and
you've lost a million dollars. You're
not going to go home after losing a
million dollars. like no no no my luck
my luck will turn around right
and also like if I go home my wife is
going to shout at me for the rest of my
life so screw that I'm going to stay
here right so some cost fallacy mission
creep the Pentagon will not abandon this
war it will only escalate you've got
tens of thousands of troops being
transported to the Middle East anyway
right so all the ingredients are in
place for a major escalation okay so
you'll see a ground invasion of Iran in
which case it's going to be a quackmire.
America's going to be stuck there for
four years I think is optimistic. Four
years is optimistic possibly 10 20
years. Okay. So so that's one
prediction. Another p prediction is
that
um the midterms will not go the way
people expect them to go. I'm not saying
they'll be cancelled, but but what I'm
saying is that right now Donald Trump
and the Republicans are trying to pass
something called the Save America Act,
right? Which is say that they want voter
ID.
Now, the Democrats are saying that that
voter ID is akin to voter suppression.
And what the reason why is
um if you have voter ID laws then you
need ICE officers
in the polling stations and we know what
ICE is like right so um we can imagine
that there'll be intimidation there'll
be some fraud going on in November um
there may there may also be a
cancellation of certain elections
I don't know how the midterms will turn
out. But what I will say is that it's
almost insignificant how the midterms
turn out because it's possible the
Republicans stay uh they maintain a
house and a Senate, in which case um
Donald Trump continues his war. It's
also possible the Democrats put up
people call the blue dogs who are
national security apparatus uh people
who are Democratic. Okay, so these these
are people who are SIA who are in
Pentagon and they would support this
war. So they come in into office and
they would impeach Donald Trump if he
continue this war. Okay, but it's also
possible the Democrats sweep sweep and
they impeach Donald Trump and this
wouldn't change anything because he
still has the power to um fight this war
to to the bitter end which and if he's
get gets impeached you can imagine that
he he'd be even more determined to fight
uh this war. So, I don't know what the
midterms will turn out. But I will say
that it will not be the way people
expect it to to work out. I think
there'll be a lot of surprises. And I
will also say it won't change the
trajectory of this war. I think the tra
trajectory of this war is already set.
Okay. I will also say that by 2027,
you should have the framework for
national draft already in place. It is
possible they've already um passed
legislation to um create the national
draft. Um or it's possible
that um certain people have already been
drafted. Um I think
by 2027 ICE will be much more powerful
than people imagine. I think I think
they want to deploy National Guard to
all major cities in America because
they're preparing for
uh economic collapse. They're preparing
for financial collapse. They're
preparing for the National Draft. They
will need law enforcement and National
Guard in all the major cities,
especially in Democratic cities like Los
Angeles and Boston and Chicago, uh where
they expect us the resistance to be the
greatest. um by 2027 all the ingredients
for civil war should already be in
place. Um I don't mean actually you know
two militaries fighting each other but
I'm saying like n n n n n n n n n n n n
n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n
n n n n n n n n nationwide discontent
and riots and protests and insurgencies.
Okay, so this is going to be low-level
conflict but it's going to be uh what
the civil war will look like for the
next few years. Um so um the global
economy should have collapsed by uh
24/7. So JP Morgan has reports saying
that the world will run out run out of
oil
um by the end of this month
>> and that's because of the closing of the
straight. right because of the closing
of the straight home moves.
>> But the world the problem of the world
is that people are used to efficiency
which is say getting resources as
cheaply and as quickly as possible and
the entire world is structured around
efficiency
and the problem though is that
efficiency and resilience are at odds
with each other. So the example is just
in time inventory right? So um companies
don't have inventory because they don't
want to be the cost of inventory. So
they just use just in time um um supply
chains meaning like you will only keep
this thing in place for a couple days
before you ship it to another place. But
what happens if there's a choke choke
hold right on on on the supply network
like the st moves? Well then then your
entire system implodes
>> because there's not enough inventory to
go around. people aren't stocked up on
necessities, right? So, this crisis that
we're seeing uh in the global economy
will only get worse and it's going to
extend to every aspect of life where you
think, okay, well, I don't drive a car
or I don't fly a plane for the next
year. Like, no, no, no, no. That's not
how that's how these things work, man.
Cheap energy is the foundation of the
entire modern global economy. So it's
not just
travel, it's also food, man. You know,
it's possible they have to start
rationing food. So a few days ago, um,
Prime Minister Albanese of Australia and
Prime Minister Kurt Steimemer of the UK
start to address their nations.
And basically their point is, and it is
very subtle language, but their point is
buckle up guys, okay? Okay? Because
right now it's going to be food
shortages, but but imagine if there are
um food rationing going on, right? So,
this is a world that's unimaginable for
most people, but it's a world of
um
of limited resources. It's a it's a it's
a world of re resource conflict, and
it's a a world um in transition, of
collapse.
So, um, buckle up.
>> Would you predict that by the end of
2027 will be the destruction of Al Axa?
>> Yeah. Okay. So, let's go into what we
know about Alex so far. Okay. So, um,
there was a Jewish rabbi who was very
well known in Israel, but last June
during the 12-day war between Israel,
United States, and and Iran, he said
basically, "Wow, this war would be the
perfect opportunity to stage a false
flag operation where the Iranian missile
is flying over Alex Mos. If we demolish
it and we blame it on the Iranians, then
the Persians and the Arabs would go to
war against each other and we could
laugh our heads off, what a great way to
to resolve the conflict in the Middle
East. Okay, so that's one piece of
evidence. Another piece of evidence is
uh the idea of the red heer. Um, and so
the Jews, the Methanic Jews want to
rebuild Solomon's temple, build a third
temple. But to do so, you need you need
to consecrate the ground.
So you need to make a a red heer
sacrifice. But according to the Bible,
the red heer has to be perfect. And so
there's this guy, this farmer in Texas
who spent years and years and millions
of dollars
um genetically engineering perfect red
heers, then he shipped them to Israel.
And so once they have
um all said destroyed, they can make
they make the red hers sacrifice and
then build the third temple. Okay, the
third temple itself has already been
designed and built.
brick by brick. There's something called
the temple institute in Jerusalem and
they have built the third temple
like but and all they do is move the
third temple from the current location
to the mosque location.
So this can happen right away. Okay,
that's another piece of evidence. Also,
we know that there have been ar
archaeological digs under the exac
mosque these past two years.
So if you want to control demolition,
right? Well, that's what you do. You
pretend it's an archeological dig. You
implant explosives under the AIC mosque
and then you pretend it's an Iranian
missile and then you blow up the AIC
mosque and then problem solve, right?
It's not We didn't do it. It was the
Iranian who blew it up. Then you had
Netanyahu last week say that an Iranian
missile was just so close to the Alex
mosque and he said, "Oh, you know, it's
was so close and there's there's a great
danger that the Iranians will blow up
all these holy sites, the the church of
the holy supper, the um uh Western Wall,
the um uh mosque. The Iranians are that
crazy. So watch out. It could happen."
Okay. So, you have all these things
lined up and like you have to believe
that given the fact that right now
Israel is run by these religious
fanatics, given the fact that for
decades these religious fanatics in
America, the Christian Zionists have
been supporting Israel and given the
fact that this war provides perfect
pretext
and excuse to destroy the mos, they'll
probably try something. Okay. But when I
I don't I can't say it could be 20 27.
It determines on how the war goes. Um I
and also like the thing about these
religious people is they believe in
astrology. They believe in in
numerology. Okay. So they have so if
they were to do this there has to be a
ritual and there has to be a
astrological alignment.
Right.
>> Right. So, they have a planet out, but
like I don't have access to this
information, so I can't tell you, but
they probably haven't planned it out.
And they'll probably enact a ritual um
involving a false flag in order to
destroy the Isaac mosque. That That's my
guess.
That part really fascinates me. Um and I
think we'll touch into that later in the
interview. But what would that trigger
theoretically the destruction of Alex
Mosque?
>> Right. So, I I I think they've already
telegraphed the plan, which is like
they'll pretend it's an missile.
>> Yeah. And then they'll do a control
demolition of the mosque and they'll
blame it on the on the Iranians. And at
this point, the war will be so confusing
because Americans have sent in ground
troops and the war is raging on multiple
fronts where the Iranians are also
destroying the oil refineries,
dissolvation plants of the Middle East.
The world, the whole world, especially
Africa is in terrible terrible economic
um um is in a terrible economic
situation. there there might be a food
shortage in Africa. There could be a
famine in Africa and so the entire world
is sort of like distracted. Right.
>> Right. So then the Alex and Moss is
blown up and like people like what? What
was that? What is the Alex mosque?
Right. Because like people don't have
enough food to eat. There's rioting in
the streets. The grocery stores are
empty.
Right? People don't people argue like
okay well you know I don't have a job
and my bank account count has gone to
zero and there's no food and like
everyone's fighting each other like like
who cares about the mosque
>> right because it was an accidental
destruction in theory do you think we're
heading toward nuclear warfare
>> I am convinced
nuclear weapons will will not be used in
this war and the reason why is according
to game theory
Iran,
Israel, and United States do not benefit
at all from the use of tactical nuclear
weapons. Okay, so let's go with Iran.
Okay, Iran could in three weeks build 10
nuclear devices because they have the
uranium and the technology to build a um
nuclear weapon is actually open source.
You can actually go online and build and
find this information. Okay, it's not
that hard. If Pakistan can build a
nuclear weapon, so can Iran. Okay. So,
but Iran's not going to do that. And the
reason why is that for them, it's very
important to maintain the moral high
ground. And also,
the only way they can lose this war is
if nukes start flying, right? So, you
have 10 nukes.
Okay, you might destroy Israel, but then
America has thousands of nuclear weapons
to destroy you, right? So, that's not
strategic. And the Iranians have
demonstrated that they are very
strategic and very uh thoughtful in
their actions. They've shown a lot of
restraint in this war uh so far. Okay.
So Iran's not that interested in using
nuclear weapons.
They they probably don't even want a
nuclear weapon. Okay.
Israel is getting all at once, right?
Because Israel is trying to achieve the
greater Israel project. They're trying
to control the Middle East. So it needs
America and Iran to destroy each other.
Right now, they're targeting they're
starting to target uh Iran's critical
civil infrastructure, including
desalination plants, including power
plants. In fact, Donald Trump has
threatened to blow up every single power
plant in Iran if he's losing this war.
Um recently, I I think I think I think
yesterday really, the Americans blew up
a a civilian bridge. Okay. So, as this
war escalates, the Americans are going
to blow up every single piece of
critical civil infrastructure in Iran,
including bridges, power plants,
reservoirs, the disaster plants. So,
that's going to take, you know, a few
years for Iran to recover. So, Iran's
not going to be a threat to Israel in
the long term. Okay? America will send
in ground troops into Iran at some point
to win this war and it'll be a quackmire
for the Americans. They might send
100,000. They might send a half million.
Who knows? But regardless of how many
they send in, they're still going to
lose the war because um Iran is much too
big and the Iranians are much much more
much too determined, right? So be like
another Vietnam in which case Americans
are forced out of the Middle East and
Sen, the entire American military
infrastructure then goes to Israel,
right? Israel now becomes the dominant
power in the Middle East. So for
Israel's from Israel's perspective, you
don't even want to win this war. You
don't even want to participate in this
war. You just want America and Iran to
duke it out for as long as possible,
>> right? So why use nuclear weapons,
right? the United States is if you're
Donald Trump, you know, you're you're
trying to rebuild America
and
um
you're you don't really care actually
what happens in the Middle East. You win
this war, great. You lose this war, I I
can deal with that. You care more about
what happens in America. You care about
using the national giraffe. You care
about about ICE. You care about uh
election tempering in order to
consolidate your power in America. That
that's the thing about war. War drives
political transformation.
>> And so Peter Hexev yesterday fired three
top military generals. You can do that
in a war because they're not obeying
you. They're not following their orders.
Right? So war is a great mechanism of
political transformation
and that's what Donald Trump is focused
on. Right? So you want to drag this war
out as long as possible because that
gives you more power. Right? So there
was a press conference between um
Vladimir Zalinski and Donald Trump
and um basically a reporter asked
Zilinski um hey when are you going to
retire man? You've been president for
how long? And Zanski is like well we're
in a war so we've suspended the
constitution. And Donald Trump was like
you can actually do that and like said
to him oh yeah you like that don't you?
Right. So so he's telegraphing to you
his intentions. They're not joking here.
Right. So the the longer this war drags
on, the the more that America is mired
down in the Middle East, the more Donald
Trump benefits politically and
personally. So why would he use nuclear
weapons?
Professor Jang, a lot of what you
predict is driven by economics. So
before we get into your next major
prediction,
you said money is alchemy used by the
elites to enslave us. Sure.
>> Why do you think consumerism is the
perfection of slavery and why do you see
money as alchemy?
>> Okay. All right. So, um this is a really
complicated question. Okay. So, I want
to introduce two philosophers to help us
structure our discussion. The first is
Emanuel Kant. What Emanuel Kant says is
that there's no objective reality.
Everything is a creation of our
imagination.
Right? So he differentiates between nana
and phenomena.
>> Nomina are the things in themselves.
The phenomena are the things to us. And
so what we do every day is we
participate in reality. We create
reality because we filter reality using
time and space. So time and space exists
to us. Um they are what is called the
ego. But time and space don't actually
actually exist outside of us.
And so that's a really important idea to
understand that reality is a
hallucination. It's a collective
creation. So whatever we imagine real
reality it to be reality becomes. Okay.
So that's the first idea. Second idea is
Plato's cave. So in his book the
republic Plato writes about the allegory
of the cave. So imagine
um a cavern and everyone about a million
people are living there. They're all
lined up one by one serving at a wall.
Okay? And they're chained to this wall
and their necks are shackled down. So
they can't even move their necks to look
around them. They can only stare
directly
into the wall.
And behind them are some people. They
okay Plato never clarifies who they are.
Doesn't really matter who they are. But
what they do is they there's a fire
behind them and they take puppets and
they reflect these puppets onto the
wall. And so we the only thing we can
see is the wall, right? So we see these
shadows and we think that this is
reality itself. Okay? We we know better.
You and I know better. But the people
inside the cave because they've never
been outside. They've never seen
sunlight. They don't understand the
concept of shadows. So they think these
shadows are reality itself. And so what
they do is they give names to the
shadows. They create stories out of
these shadows. They create a religion
out of these shadows.
So what these shadows are are way to
structure and direct and focus our
attention.
And in our world, that's what money is.
Okay? Money is alchemy. It doesn't exist
outside of us. It's only because we
believe it has value. It has value.
So now the question is
how did we get to this system? How was
this system created? Well, believe it or
not, but for the longest time, money was
not an issue for people. So for example,
uh let's go to the Vikings. If you're a
Viking, what you did was you spent most
of your time farming or fishing, but now
and then you you and your mates got
together and you go and raided a Irish
village or an English village for fun.
Okay. Um and you would target
monasteries because in monasteries there
was a lot of gold.
>> Um um they would uh print books and then
the uh book covers would have a lot of
gold, especially Bibles. And then they
would take this gold and maybe sell it.
They might capture some slaves and then
they would sell it to the Ottomans or
the Bison teams, whoever. Okay? And so
they would make a lot of money in these
raids. The moment they got back home,
they spent all this money on a feast for
the community. And that's like literally
how people spent their money. They
didn't save it because there was no
point. Right.
>> Right. What like like I mean you could
save your money by digging a hole and
putting all the gold in the ground, but
like that's but why would you do that?
That was that that was pointless. What
you cared about was your reputation
among your peers. What you cared about
is was a community. What you cared about
was leaving a legacy, a memory. And so
the memory was not um money. The memory
was the stories. And that's why they
went and raided these Irish villages and
these British v villages. Not because
they want the gold. The gold was useful.
But what what was more useful to them
was the stories that they could tell
their friends about how they went over
and killed a lot of people and did all
that did all all these amazing things.
That's what their social currency was,
right? What they want to do was like sit
in their long houses in the cold of
winter and there's a fire and they would
tell each other these stories of, you
know, this great hero who went to
Iceland and founded the colony there and
then he died for some for some silly
reason. Okay. But they had all these
great stories and we still have them
today. The the the um sagas, right? The
north sagas. And and you know they're
wonderful stories and that's how most
people live their lives in human
history. This changed at a very
particular time in human history. The
year is 1694. Okay. 1694.
The reason why is the bank of England
was chartered in uh England at this
time. 1688 is something called the
glorious revolution. So think of the
glorious revolution as a marriage
between two protestant uh empires, the
British and the Dutch Republic. And at
this time in history, the Dutch Republic
were the wealthiest people in the world
because they control the spice trade in
the Far East. So their ships went to the
far east, collected spice and then um um
sold it through throughout Europe. And
spice at the time in history was the
most valuable commodity in the world
because it made your food taste better,
right? You couldn't actually use gold,
but you could use spices. So spices were
the most valuable commodity in the
world, especially from Far East.
Cinnamon, nutmeg, peppercorn, these
things.
The problem with the Dutch Republic is
that it was inland. And so the Holic
Empire, the Catholic Church, uh the the
Spanish would come and conquer you,
right? So there this there's real
anxiety where they were generating so
much wealth, but they had to protect
this wealth. So they decided like the
best place to put your wealth was an
island somewhere that no one can invade.
That was of course England. So you have
this marriage between England and the
Dutch Republic.
And now the question then is okay you
have all this wealth generated by the
Dutch but how do you use it? How do you
store it? How do you um make more wealth
creation? Okay. And wait sorry um I
missed a very important point.
>> Before no one cared about wealth
creation.
>> There was no point. But suddenly the
Dutch cared about wealth creation. The
reason why is they were covenants. Okay.
So before the Protestant reformation
um everyone was a Catholic in Europe and
they believe that if I if I do good
works if I obey the church I would go to
heaven. So it's called just
justification by works. If I just obey
the Catholic church I could go to
heaven. But over time the Catholic
Church start to abuse this privilege. It
became very corrupt. It started to sell
um privileges to people. You know, if
you were like a terrible, terrible
aristocrat, uh, you committed all sorts
of sins, but you had a lot of money, the
Catholic Church will be think, "Oh,
that's fine. We'll we'll forgive you."
>> And that's indulgences.
>> Exactly. The word is indulgence. That
that is correct. And the idea of
indulgences is that you don't go to
hell, you go to purgatory, and then you
go then you go to heaven. Because
technically, you know, if you've done
all this evil in the world, we should go
to hell. Okay. But if you paid the
Catholic Church enough money, the
indulgence, then um uh you could go to
purgatory and shorten your stay there.
And um in order to build these
monumental churches like St. Peter's
Basil Basilica, the church was selling
indulgences just left and right to
anyone. Okay, so it's this massive
corruption scam. And so obviously a lot
of people would be very angry at this.
And so people like uh Martin Luther and
John Calvin, they started to question
the authority of the church. And their
main dispute, theological dispute is you
shouldn't be able to go to heaven just
because you have money or because you
bribe the priest. You should go to
heaven because you have faith. But then
the question then is like how do you
prove you have faith?
And so John Calvin proposed the idea of
um double predestination. And the idea
of double predestination is that at the
beginning of time, okay, before God
created anything, he determined who we
go to heaven and who go to hell. That's
double predestination. So it didn't
really matter if you obey the Catholic
Church. It really didn't the Catholic
Church had no authority over you. So
just ignore it and focus on your own
eternal salvation. Right? But then the
question is like okay then how do you
know that you're one of the elect? Well
because you're successful in life
because of your wealth. So the more
wealth you generate the more you know
that God favors you. But it was
important not to spend this wealth
because then you show you are lustful,
you are sinful, right? So this creates a
very complex psychology where you are
anxious to make as much money as
possible but you can't spend any of it
because you don't want to show that you
are sinful
>> and this is what led to the modern
financial system right because now the
Dutch Republic everyone's putting the
money in the bank and so the Dutch
Republic can now take this wealth and
then invest it in other places okay and
this is what leads to capitalism and why
is wealth specifically like a sign that
you're favored by God, right? So, um the
question is
how do you prove you're one of the elect
to yourself as well as to others
>> and the and the answer is through your
success because at this time in history
people everyone believes in God and
everyone believes that God is a source
of your luck.
>> Right.
>> Right. So if you have a good life, it
means because you've been a pious person
and God favors you. If you became a very
wealthy person, that also shows you that
God favors you, right? So wealth is the
clearest indicator that to the community
that you're a good person, right?
Because before it was about
storytelling, like how good of a
storyteller were you? Now it's about
wealth crequation. How good of a
businessman are you? Right. Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense to me. I
think it's the concept of like
resourcefulness because
the claim is that people throughout
history didn't value money but they
always thought that having resources was
a sign that you were favored by the
gods. That's right. Okay.
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> Okay.
>> And they defined resources differently
in different times.
>> Right.
>> Right. So, um the Dutch Republic has all
this wealth. It can't spend it. But if
it just leaves in a bank all this gold,
the Spanish are going to come and steal
it. Okay. So they transfer all this gold
to England which has a royal navy and
which can protect this gold. Okay. But
now the question then is how do you
ensure that this gold creates more
wealth because it's important to create
wealth to show you are part of the elect
right. So in 1694 they created something
called the bank of England.
And the idea of the bank of England is
very simple. This be a private bank.
Okay? Meaning like if you put this gold
into this bank, it's your gold. It's
private because you you have to prove to
yourself and to God that you are
wealthy, right?
And and the deal is this.
Parliament,
the nation state would borrow this money
from you in order to finance wars
because before the relationship was um
wars at the time was fought by by
mercenaries. So you you need a lot of
gold, you need a lot of like um capital.
And so kings would borrow money from
merchants usually. The problem is that
the king could die, the king could lose
the war, or the king could just be like,
I don't need to pay you back because I'm
the king and you're not, right? So
there's a real risk uh when you lend
money to the king. But now that you lend
money to parliament, now it's safe
because every person in a country is
obligated to pay back the debt. Uh
regardless of how poor this nation
becomes as long as the nation state is
still standing, as long as parliament
has authority, parliament must pay you
back. Okay? So the idea is the bank of
England has all this private wealth and
now it lends this money what we call
money printing to parliament in order
for parliament to finance public works
projects, finance wars, finance
everything. Okay? And this led to the
creation of the British Empire. The
problem with this is now Parliament
needs to expand this wealth. And how do
you do that? Well, you conquer other
territories, right? You go start wars
and this is what led to the expansion of
the British Empire. This is what led to
the colonization of um India. This is
what led to
um um the open wars in China where
Britain uh forced drugs upon the Chinese
population because you're constantly
looking for new markets in order to
extract wealth and and and this is what
creates the idea of transnational
capital. Okay. Um the first principle is
the creation of wealth for the for the
purpose of wealth creation. Okay, no
other ends. It's not to make a better
society. It's not to make a better
world. It's not to improve the life of
humanity. It's just wealth creation and
that's all and that's all they care
about. And that's number one. Number two
is it's transnational meaning what they
care most about is the liquid movement
of capital around the world. So wherever
there's an opportunity, they want to
move that capital. So an example of
course is America's guilded age when
America was rapidly industrializing and
so the city of London uh the Bank of
England um shifted a lot of transational
capital to America. The problem with
America though is Americans hated
uh the British at this time and they
hated transational capital because they
saw transational capital as a source of
all evil.
So what they did which was which was
very clever is they had agents
um that they handpicked
in order to um promote transential
capital in America and these people all
called Johnny Rockefeller
Andrew Carnegie Commodore Vanderbilt
that's how they became very wealthy
right because think about think about
this how Johnny Rockefeller came from
nothing and before he died he
monopolized the entire oil industry in
America. How did he do that? Like just
do the math. It's impossible to like
monopolize an entire nation's oil. You
can monopolize maybe Ohio
or Florida. Sure, I can understand that.
But when you monopolize the entire
nation of America,
that's ridiculous. Okay. And so I think
the best logical explanation is that
transnational capital see like
recognized his potential and backed him
and gave him the financing to buy all
his competitors which makes the most
logical sense right. Um so so that's
what transational capital does. It's
only interested in wealth creation. It
moves capital around from place to
place. Has actually no loyalty to nation
and it believes in open borders. It
believes in uh it it sees religion as a
threat. It sees monarchies as a threat.
And most people don't appreciate this
but transational capital also financed
the creation of Marxism.
>> Okay. In two aspects. The first aspect
is if you go and look at the life of
Karl Marx, he was being um bankrolled by
Frederick Engles. Frederick Angel's
father was an industrialist. So this is
transnational capital. And why would
they finance Karl Marx? And Karl Mar
spent most of his life in Britain.
Right? So that's the first example.
Second example is if you look at the
Bolsheviks, this was a extreme French
political party in Russia that no one
liked. Everyone thought these people are
crazy. They're fanatics.
But they had access to transnational
capital. They were financed by Wall
Street. And so during the
revolution
um transnational capital was bankrolling
them so that they could hire mercenaries
to fight the war. They could bribe
foreign governments not to intervene.
They could pay off um generals of the
white armies and that's how they won the
war with the help of um transnational
capital. So um this economy between
capitalism and communism it's it's all a
false dialectic. It's meant to deceive
you. Ultimately what transational
capital is interested in is in seeking
better investment opportunities and
bullshum made Russia a better investment
opportunity for transational capital.
Right? Because be because before you had
the zar and you had the orthodox church
and both were opposed to transational
capital. They saw as the antichrist
system. They still call it the
antichrist system. Um
>> are you saying that communism was
created by capitalist?
>> Yes. in order to um um pave the way for
the infiltration of trans national
capital into the world,
>> right? Because who opposes money? Well,
the king opposes transational capital
because he doesn't want his the national
sovereignty to be uh destroyed, right?
Kings oppose trans national capital. Who
else opposes trans national capital?
Religious people, right? because you see
money as a source of all evil. Like
guys, let's not focus on making money.
Let's just focus on uh praying to God,
on being good people,
>> right? So with communism,
communism is for it's considered like
the apex of the enlightenment because it
puts reason above everything else. It
puts it puts reason above God, country
and king and no other philosophy did
that before. Right. So communism was
crucial to the de development and
conquest of transnational capital.
>> Was it a controlled opposition for them
pretty much?
>> Um so
>> like it was made to be an enemy. So
people promoted capitalism which in turn
promotes transnational capital.
>> Right. Okay. So what we what we need to
understand is for transational capital
to win it need to create an entire
worldview an entire religion or entire
philosophy
uh so that it can infiltrate your mind
right because again throughout most of
human of human history we didn't care
about money we care about the community
we cared about our status in the
community so what transial capital did
was not not not only did it sponsor
um Marxism but also sponsored other
movements as well that were key to
creating the world that we live in.
Okay. So one person that they sponsored
was John Lock who uh proposed that
private property is an intrinsic right
given to you by God and and this was new
at this time.
>> At this time in history people were
pious and they didn't really care about
private property. They cared about um
their faith. They cared about their
community. They cared about the
relationship with God. Now John Lock is
saying that private property is
something given to you by God and
therefore it is protected by God.
Another idea idea he he promoted was
something called impericism which is to
say you can only know things that you
experience. And this is again a
radically different concept from
religion which is you should feel God in
you. And there are these spirits, holy
spirits around you. And John's saying,
"No, no, no, no, guys. You're just
hallucinating. You're delusional. It's
things only exist if you can experience
them yourself. You can't just imagine
things. You just can't believe these
things. You have to be able to see these
things, right? And this gives us um
David Hume who who promoted the idea of
skepticism, which is to say, you know
what, even things you see may not be
true." Okay?
uh you have to be skeptical about
everything you believe because a lot of
things you believe may just be a product
of custom and memorization as opposed to
um um reality itself. So he he gives an
example of let's just say you've seen
10,000 white swans. Now you can induce
the idea of induction that all swans are
white.
>> But is that really true? Well, it's not
true because there are black swans. Not
that many, but there are. which which is
to say that all knowledge is based on
induction,
right? Because there it's impossible for
you to see all swans. If you've seen
10,000 swans and they're all white, you
have to believe that all swans are
white.
But that's not true, right? Which which
is to say that your inductive ability is
very limited.
So so so David Hume is questioning the
very project of philosophy.
He's questioning the very project of um
enlightenment
and um science. Okay. So that's then you
have Jeremy Bentham who and his idea is
this you have um you you can only know
things that you experience and even
these things you experience you cannot
know to be true. So you can't actually
appeal to universal principles. So
what's the solution to to this crisis?
Utility. If it's useful to you, it must
be good. What? What is useful? It gives
you pleasure. It must be good. How do
you know? How do you know money creation
is good? Because money creation, you can
buy things and buying these things gives
you pleasure.
Therefore, you know it's good. And then
from Jeremy Bentham, you have John Sut
Mill, his proteége. And then John
Stewart Mill takes this idea of
utilitarianism and applies it to all
society which is to say that
how can we judge whether or not social
policy is good or not
because it's useful because it appeals
to our sense of pleasure. Therefore
feminism is good because it brings women
into society. Therefore, liberalism is
good because it empowers the individual
and all these ideas together then form a
framework for modern society.
Right? But again what's important is
these ideas are are an outgrowth of
transnational capital and its uh demand
to control reality itself, our
perception of reality itself by making
the world more materialistic by by
making money the main organizing
principle of reality whereas before it
might have been God or love or family or
community. Do you think people in the
west are more free today than slaves
were?
>> Yeah. So what I've argued before is that
if you take the principle
um of empiricism, skepticism and
utilitarianism to its logical extreme,
you end up with consumerism.
And I've argued before that consumerism
is the perfection of slavery.
Because what makes this free
um and I'm going to get a bit wonky
here, okay? Or a bit um um it might
confuse you. So feel free to interrupt.
Feel free feel free to ask me any
clarifying questions. But what makes us
free is our connection
to the divine.
Because once you recognize that
our ego is an illusion, time and space
is an illusion. And what we are are
psychic beings that are
interdimensional, that are unified with
the universal consciousness that have
access to God. Then what you recognize
is this. Death does not matter. Death is
a release. Our souls can escape our husk
and return to the divine.
And we are only here to experience the
world for what it is, which is a
material world. But at the end of the
but at the end of the day, this material
existence is just a small speck of our
entire consciousness or of our entire
existence of our soul. So don't be so
focused on material acquisition in this
world because once you leave it, you
can't take it with you. But what you can
take with you are
memories,
experiences
that shine a light on the universe.
We're here to shine a light on the
universe by doing things by engaging
activities
that are not available to the divine
consciousness.
And one example is to fall in love with
someone. Yeah, you can't do that up
there because we're all one. We're all
one being. We're all unified. But here
because we are trapped in our husk our
bodies
and there's a divine light that shines
in us we our divine light as aspires to
return to the divine and the body traps
us with these animal instincts. Right?
So the body wants sex, it wants money.
It wants pleasure. But the divine spark
wants unity. It wants coherence. It
wants creativity, imagination. Okay, so
these are two two competing forces
within us and we're trapped in this body
and we believe that this body is who we
are. So how can we actually
ignite that spark in us and connect more
with the divine consciousness? And the
answer is by finding another spark
and finding connection with that spark
and then together you affect each
other's light and then you grow and grow
and that opens your mind and connects
you to the divine consciousness while
simultaneously you're still living your
life. That's why love is love is
important, right? And and Dante talks
about this in the divine comedy where
love is about generosity. It's about
kindness. It's about uh forgiving. So
find someone you love and just love that
person for the rest of your life. And
that's how you can truly be be human.
>> And that's the path to enlightenment.
That's a path to
um freedom. But but without that,
without belief in God, without love,
we're always trapped inside ourselves.
And we try to escape this trap by
indulging in material pleasures which
actually increases the strength of our
prison.
Freedom is the belief that you are both
nothing and everything. Freedom is the
belief that love conquers all. Love will
set you free. That's what freedom is. I
guess to
understand how this relates to I guess
the future of where we're going in the
world.
Do the people making the decisions that
are important to kind of unravel history
over the next hundred years? Do they
believe in the do they live their life
based off consumerism off of hoarding
wealth or do they live their life off of
what you had referenced with
prioritizing love? So transential
capital is first and foremost focused on
wealth creation and that basically means
creating more materialism in this world
and
um so these people are still Calvinist.
Um right. So
Calvinism is what sparked this
intellectual revolution. But over time
um this idea of wealth creation becomes
an end to itself. Right? Because of the
enlightenment before you created wealth
in order to be closer to God to prove
that God favored you. And then with the
enlightenment, with the second
revolution, with secularism,
um,
uh, materialism became an end onto
itself, wealth creation be became an end
onto itself. And the reason why is
as long as people believe in God,
there's a check and a balance to off
creation, right? because well um we we
have to remember that we're creating
this wealth to show our faith in God but
what matters is our faith in God but
that's problematic because maybe other
people don't really believe in God right
so in China we don't really believe in
God
um in East Asia we we don't believe in
God or or maybe other people believe in
different gods or maybe people are not
Calvinists so if you really want to
expand wealth creation you have to make
it a universal idea idea, right? And the
way you do that is by making money
itself to God.
>> The next date I have here for your
predictions is 2030. So
>> in the year 2030, what does that look
like?
>> Okay, so we're going through a
tumultuous period of systems change
which will ultimately lead to systems
collapse. Okay, so let me explain to you
what the system is today.
>> All right, so tential capital is a very
important concept, right? But but I I
want to show you how it creates this
world and structures this world. Okay.
All right. So at the very core of our
world is the idea of empire.
Okay. And the empire of course is Pax
Americana. Basically the ability of
America's military to project power
anywhere in the world, right? Creating
the the aura of ine inevitability and
invitability. Okay. When we discussed
this, right? But that's the basis of
everything. Okay? People's fear of the
empire.
And then the empire allows um this game
to be created and these are the
financiers.
Okay, so this is transational capital
basically. But they create the game that
we live in because again money is not
valuable. Money is just a mechanism to
store and extract wealth which is what?
Which is our attention, our
consciousness.
Okay? Because our consciousness is the
source of all reality. So if you control
and focus a person's consciousness, you
can create reality itself. Okay. So
money is a mechanism to focus our
attention and then extract our attention
to store it properly. Okay? And um let
let me give you an example. All right?
Just say that I ask you to make a vase
to sell.
While you're making this vase, you're
indifferent. You're like, "Whatever, I
don't really care." So you listen to
music. um you're watching TV as you make
this vase. You're not really attentive.
>> Well, the vase is going to be pretty
ugly, which means you can't sell it for
that much, right? But let's just say for
the reason you want you want to make the
most beautiful vase in the world. You're
completely focused on it. You see a
purpose and a meaning in creating this
vase. May maybe because you're giving it
to your mother or your wife or whatever,
but you spend days and days just
pondering
just focused on it. It becomes your life
itself. It it creates a sensation in you
called flow. Uh which is a concept uh
coined by a psychologist named Texi. But
it's it's the most creative stage anyone
can achieve where you're where you lose
a sense of time and space itself where
you just focus on the create act of
creation so that you become the act of
creation itself. Right? So a painter
goes through this where you know painter
is drawing a picture and um he or she
becomes so enamored with this picture
that he or she doesn't sleep, doesn't
eat, doesn't drink water, doesn't go to
the bathroom because he or she's so
focused on him. Okay, that's attention.
When you do that, whatever you create is
going to be valuable,
right? And then money is a way to
store and extract that value. But what
creates this value was your
consciousness, was your attention. And
that's a really important principle to
understand. Okay.
All right. So the finance people use
money as a mechanism in order to extract
and store your attention.
And the way they do that is by making
money universal
which means that everyone has to use it
and money can use can be used for
anything. Okay, that's the idea of
universality. Um
and this creates the global economy.
Okay, because basically the entire
global economy is run on the US dollar.
It it's what facilitates trade, right?
It's why we go to work. It's why it's
how we pay for things, right? So that's
that's creat
um but you cannot allow people to think
this is this is how the system works
because then people lose faith in this
system, right? If if people understand
that money is just a currency no
different from monopoly money, then
people aren't going to work hard at it.
So they needed to create an artifice, a
superructure to disguise the fact and
give meaning and value to money itself.
Okay? You do that by creating something
called the rules-based international
order. Okay? Or maybe the UN, the World
Trade Organization
and this becomes the substitute for the
financeers who have the real power.
Okay? And the financers include Wall
Street, state of London, the Federal
Reserve, Bank of International
Settlements. Okay? It's is this is one
group one group of people in different
guises. Okay.
>> All right. So now you have the rules
based international order and then you
create uh culture
media
and education
in order to brainwash or indoctrinate
people into believing that this is a
system this rules based international
order that is the basis for reality
itself. Okay. As opposed to our
imagination. Right. Right. And that's
why people are saying, "Oh, Donald Trump
went to um invade Iran." That's against
international law. He should be tried at
at Nerburgg. There should be a Nermberg
trial for Donald Trump. That's silly,
man.
>> I mean, it's the empire that can
everything. But people for whatever
reason believe there is a rules based
international order. If you defy it, the
police will come and arrest you and put
you on trial. They literally believe
that. All right. And and and and but
then you ask them like, "Well, then
who's going to do that?" They're like,
"Well, the United Nations." like okay
does the United States have a military
that can defeat the American military
and but like like they are but it become
so it doesn't make much sense but they
don't really care it's the it's it's
their sense of reality itself okay and
because it's been brainwashing to them
through popular culture through uh media
like New York Times and uh BBC and
through the uh education system the
universities basically okay and then
this creates the um the values and norms
right
All right. So, this is the superructure
of the world. Okay. Does this make sense
to you?
>> I believe so. Can you summarize it one
more time?
>> All right. Let's do it again. Okay. All
right. So, think of Plato's allego the
cave,
>> right?
>> Where everyone is chained to the floor
and they can only stare at front at the
wall. Okay? The empire is what changed
people to the floor and make them think
they were powerless to resist. But then
you have people
in the background creating the illusion,
creating the reality itself with these
puppets that are reflected off the fire
onto the wall. These are the game
masters. These are the financiers.
And then
um when people look at this wall, they
create a reality of it. They play a game
of like giving names to the shadows, of
pretending there's stories behind uh uh
these shadows. And this this is the
economy, the global economy,
>> right?
>> Okay. And then you you have to explain,
okay, how does this world work? Well,
you can't see the see the people behind
you. So you say, well, it comes from God
or a spiritual force. Okay? And that's
the rules based national order. And then
you like, okay, well, you need to
indoctrinate children into the system.
So you have teachers, you have uh
propagandist journalists, you have um
priests who teach children to believe
the system the m moment they're born.
>> Okay.
>> And those people believe it too. So
>> obviously,
>> right?
>> Right. Because they can't see behind
themselves. If they turn around, they
see who's who's really pull pulling the
strings, but they can't turn around. So
they can only stare in front. So
transnational capital is trying to make
us or has made us believe that money is
God, but I guess what's the I know this
is a complex topic, but what's the
single most important thing people need
to know about money to know that it's
fake and something that they can
>> Yeah. Okay. Really simple idea. Okay.
All right. So there's a bank
and people think that bank is a place
where they take the deposit of money and
they use it to fuel the economy by
lending to entrepreneurs.
Right? And that's what drives the
economy. Okay? But here's the problem
though. You're the bank. Depositors put
a million dollars into the bank. Okay?
You take that million dollars and then
you give it to entrepreneurs to open a
restaurant. Okay? Right? Question is,
how much money is in the bank now? The
answer is not zero, which is what math
the math says, right? The answer is
actually $2 million.
And you're like, "Okay, um, that's kind
of stupid. Where do we get the system?"
Okay, it comes from early banking. It
comes from Venice, basically. Okay, so
back then they didn't have money. They
had gold,
>> right? So you put a million dollars of
gold into the bank. Now the bank's going
to lend this million dollars primary to
merchants who engage in trade. Okay? But
the problem is that
um you don't want to physically give
people the gold because it's dangerous.
It doesn't really do anything. So what
you do is you give them a receipt for
the gold, right? So it's like a million
dollar receipt for the gold.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> So now in your ledger, you have $2
million because that gold didn't go
away. But then you also create a receipt
for that gold which becomes currency in
itself as long as people are willing to
believe that this contract has value.
And that's how money works. So how does
this relate to the concept of I guess
what happens in 2030 and why do wars
like why are wars so important for the
global economy? Okay, so you have the
system in place. Okay, and this is the
host. Let's just call this a host.
Now you need to extract value from this
system. And you do that through
um three major mechanisms. Okay. U you
do it through intelligence,
spies basically, you do it through
crime, and you do it through science. An
example of course is Jeffrey Epstein who
was at the epicenter of both
intelligence networks, criminal networks
as well as science networks, right? And
this becomes the parasite system, right?
Because like once you create value, you
have to extract it, right? And and and
so these three things, intelligence,
crime, and science is what allows you to
extract value from the system. So then
the question then is who controls the
parasite system? Well, it's going to be
transnational capital. Doesn't Does it
make sense so far? Okay. The problem
with the system is if you are the host
and you look at the system, you think
this is not really fair, man. Why is it
that these guys get to extract rent from
everyone else? So, you're like, is it
possible to create a new system in which
case I'm the one extracting rent and not
these guys? Because all I have to do is
become the game master, right? Okay. And
so this idea called elite overp
production and this was u coined by a
historian named Peter Turchin and his
argument is this eventually societies
reach a point where power oifies becomes
bureaucratic in which case what's really
important is who controls the power as
opposed to wealth creation because
whoever controls the power is able to
use government to extract rent from
everyone else. But the problem is you
have too many people in the elite and
too few position positions of power. So
they start to compete against each other
for these positions of power. And then
your question then is okay well if the
people in finance have all the power
who's challenging them who wants their
power and the answer is the tech sector.
Silicon Valley. Silicon Valley wants to
be able to replace finance
and become the game master of this
world. And so what's their main
mechanism? Artificial intelligence,
right? AI. Because money is God, but so
is AI. Because remember, God is the
force that focuses and directs your
attention.
So money can do that but a AI is better
because go back to this wall right
everyone's with money everyone's staring
at the same wall
but with AI this wall becomes
individualized so you're staring at the
at your own individual wall that speaks
back to you so that captures your
attention even more so your thesis is
transnational capital the way they've
designed our world is that money is our
god And that the only way to beat that
system isn't to take all their money.
It's to all the money.
>> It's replace money with ahi.
>> That's right. Because you have to
replace God with some with another god.
You can't just not have god.
>> So where does that lead us in by 2030?
>> Okay. So once we understand this, okay,
we understand what's going on in the
world, which is like at the end of the
day, there's a civil war going on. Okay.
And I would say there are three ways to
conceive of the civil war. Okay. The
first way is just to see it as a
struggle between the left and the right,
which is how most people understand
what's going on in America, right? You
got this left and right divide. But you
go deeper, it becomes one of globalists
versus nationalists,
right? So globalists are people who
believe that
the rules based international order, the
transatlantic alliance, NATO, United N
United Nations, EU are all worth
preserving because they allow for elites
around the world to congregate and to uh
negotiate peaceful settlements.
>> But if you're a nationalist, what you
say to that is no, that's not true. What
this global system allows the elite to
do is steal money from the nation and
funnel it to themselves. So the
globalists are parasites,
right? So you have all this corruption
around the world. Why? Because the elite
can take all this illumin wealth and
move it to Hong Kong, move to Dubai,
move to New York, move it to London.
That's the root of all evil.
If if people are not allowed to move
money around, then they're stuck taking
care of their own people.
They're they're stuck rejuvenating their
own nation.
They're forced to make their own home a
better place because they have to live
in it. But with transnationalism, with
globalism, well, I can screw up my
African country as much as I want
because I'll be able to move my money,
my children, all my assets to London or
Dubai.
And so there's this huge conf conflict
going on between a globalist and a
nationalist. Okay. And then if you go
deeper, it's also conflict between
finance versus uh the tech sector. Okay.
Silicon Valley because finance wants to
maintain money as a god and the tech
sector wants to promote AI as the god.
Okay. So this is a way I think you can
frame all the conflict in the world. And
once we have this framing, we can
actually see how things will progress
where this where the tech sector is
going is trying to replace finance, but
finance is like screw you. I've been in
power for like hundreds of years. I'm
not going to I'm not going to go away
peacefully. So, what's going to happen
is something called a rupture where
nation states divide. Okay? Because this
conflict is going to happen within
nation states, not across nation states.
And whichever nation is able to emerge
out of this series of civil wars intact
will will prosper. Okay. So 2030 we will
see nations at civil war. America is
going to be at civil war because Donald
Trump represents the nationalists MAGA,
right? He represents Silicon Valley, the
tech people and he's and he's going to
try to implement their vision. But the
financial people are not going to go
away quietly in the night.
would you right? You're going to fight
to the end, right? And so you you have
this massive civil war break out in
America, but not just America, Europe as
well. Think about why Donald Trump hates
Europe so much because he sees Europe as
a source of transnational capital,
right? So civil war is going to break
out in Europe as well. So what's
happening is that uh the EU uh Brussels
is completely controlled by transational
capital. But who is Donald Trump
promoting in Europe? He's promoting
Poland, Hungary, Austria. He's promoting
like these nationalist parties in
Germany, AFTD,
uh Vox in Spain, Mary Le Pens party in
France. That's where the civil war is
going to be. So the grand irony of all
this is that
Putin and Trump are aligned. They want
to move the world towards a more
nationalistic
um
and the globalists are the ones fighting
back. Right?
>> So it's not a war between America and
Russia. It's a war between um the
globalists in America who are aligned
with the globalist in Europe, the
globalist in China, the globalist in
Russia versus the nationalists
in these countries. You've talked about
the three signs that an empire is going
to collapse is elite overprouction,
financialization, and rat utopia, which
is essentially is the concept of quiet
quitting, where people feel like they
can't get ahead in life. Uh
all three of these are happening
simultaneously right now in America, uh
here and and Europe as well.
Do you think we're heading toward a
global reset by 2030?
>> Right. So, I think that a lot of people
among the elite recognize that decline
is happening and there's no way around
it because of these three reasons,
right? Elite o over production, rat
utopia. Another word for ratchet utopia
is the aging crisis, right? Where you
have these old people who just won't
give up power. Right.
>> Right. And you got people like Chuck
Grassley in the Senate. He's 94, I
think.
>> That's ridiculous. Like what? Like
you're n you're like over 90 years old
and you're still sitting in the Senate,
>> right?
>> But um um so you've got these baby
boomers who refuse to surrender power
which makes the society more oified,
>> right? There's no social mobility
anymore. So that's the idea of rat
utopia. And then you have finanization
which is just to make uh America uh
which enables the elite to be parasites,
right? They do they do nothing. to
collect rent from everyone else. That's
that's what financialization is. If you
open a business in America, your return
on average might be 2%. You put your
money in a stock market, it's 5%. Who's
going to go start a business? But it's
it's starting a business that creates
wealth, that generates jobs, that makes
America strong. Okay? So, so America,
the entire world, it suffers from these
three issues. And so there's a decline.
So, there have been different
conceptions
um to deal with this. Okay. There's
there's there's a concept called manage
decline, another called the great reset.
Okay, but it's the same idea which is in
a time of decline, how do we the elite
maintain our privilege and our and our
power? And that's an impossibility
because there's too much there's too
many of you parasites. Okay, only one
faction can win out. Um so that I think
is the real issue facing the world where
the world is in decline, wealth is
decreasing and the elite are determined
to maintain their power and status and
stamp out any counter elites or
revolutionaries who want to rest his
power away from them. And that's what's
happening behind the scenes in most
major countries. Would you guess that
we'll have a major market crash by 2030?
>> I think we'll have a major market crash
by the end of this year. I I I I don't
think we have to wait till till 2030. Um
you've got massive asset inflation all
around the economy. You've got a private
credit bubble. You've got an AA bubble.
Um real estate bubble. I mean, it's just
one bubble after another. And so what
what transational capital has to do is
it needs to destroy a lot of this wealth
in order to exert more control over
society. Right? And what I mean by that
is again remember this is really
important. The point of the system is to
store and extract wealth by focusing
your attention and making you work hard.
But if you have a lot of money in the
bank, you're not going to work hard. If
your dad has a lot of money in the bank,
you won't work hard. So, they have to
destroy this wealth in order to create
more wealth. What do you think America
will look like in 2030? You've said
Trump is not trying to be president,
he's trying to be king. Do you think
Trump will be reelected for a third
term? I think Trump's going to will get
his third term. I if I were to bet good
money on it in 2028, I think Trump stays
in office. How he will do so, I'm not
completely sure of. Okay. And there are
different possibilities. It's possible
there's a war going on in which case he
can suspend the constitution. It's
possible that he runs as vice president
and his son Don Jr. vice runs as
president and then Don abdicates.
There's actually nothing in the
constitution that prevents people from
doing that. What prevents people from
doing that is convention, morality,
norms, values. Donald Trump doesn't
care, right? He's fighting for his
existence. He's fighting for his life.
Because everyone knows once Donald Trump
leaves office, what will happen? The
Democrats will use everything that they
have to destroy this guy and his entire
family for for sure, 100%. Okay. Um, so
there are different possibilities, but I
think in 2028, Donald Trump will still
be president of the United States. In
which case the question then is what
does he want to accomplish? Well, what
he wants to do is this. He wants to
transition America away from the global
economy. In which case the global
economy becomes a parasite on America,
right? Because America is the one paying
for all the defense. American consumer
is the one buying all the products.
America is is the one who's financing
the entire global economy. So he's like,
why are we doing that? Screw that.
Right? So what what what he wants to do
is uh make America into a North American
continental fortress. He wants to absorb
Canada, Greenland, Mexico.
Um the countries he's talked about that
he's pissed off or are what? Denmark,
Canada,
Mexico,
Colombia, Venezuela, Cuba, Nicaga,
Honduras. That's the entire freaking
North America. That's the north that's
something called the greater north
America which Peter Hexf has talked
about and which you know if you go back
to 1930s it's part of something called
the technocracy movement the technate
right and and the grand v the grand
vision is you know what if we create
this great greater north America we have
labor from Mexico we have resources from
Canada we are self-sufficient and the
rest of the world will beg us for our
resources
right and then we'll be we'll be very
wealthy and you know what This vision is
correct. I completely agree with this
this vision. I think Donald Trump is
correct to try to achieve this vision.
The problem is this means destroying the
current status quo. This means
destroying transational capital. This
means upsetting the current elite. So
they're going to fight you tooth and
nail. For example, Canada. Canada is not
a nation state. Canada is a resource
colony of the city of London. It's
controlled by the Brit by by by the
British monarchy. In which case, if
America would absorb Canada into greater
North America, you're basically
declaring war on Britain.
Mexico is the same situation, right?
What is transnational capital?
Transnational capital are the ones
financing
drug trafficking around the world and
money laundering, right? That's a source
of trans that's a source of a lot of
transational capitalist wealth where
during the opium wars.
Um the British were selling opium to
China and then funneling it through Hong
Kong, money laundering through Hong Kong
and now they have all these like
offshore money laundering operations
around the world. Why is Trump investing
so much naval power in the Caribbean?
because he said that he wants to disrupt
the drug trade and everyone's like
that's ridiculous. Well, what if it's
true? What if that area is a source of a
lot of of global drug trade which then
um fuels the transnational capital
elite. If you destroy that trade, you
not only hurt transational capital, but
you also hurt the deep state who are
opposed to Donald Trump, the CIA,
right?
But but but again like like they're not
stupid. Capital knows exactly what's
happening and they're not going to
surrender all their power and wealth to
this one guy,
>> right?
This is a dumb question, but you said
earlier that you can destroy a data
center and like wipe out someone's bank
account. If you were a
multi-billionaire,
do they have data centers and like that
technology on various islands
theoretically like hidden places,
>> right? So again, money is a madeup
concept, right? So if you're a
billionaire, why are you a billionaire?
You're a billionaire because you're an
agent of different transnational
networks.
>> So theirs can't be destroyed,
>> right? Because because the source of of
their wealth is their power, right? and
the and the sources of power are these
transnational networks
>> that support them. Right? So the
question is where did Jeffrey Epste get
his money? Why is Jeffrey Epste a
billionaire? And like honestly no one
knows if you just look in his
background. Okay. Well, I mean he was
making a lot of money as an arms
trafficker. um and he made a lot of
money when um Robert Maxwell died and it
seemed seemed as though he inherited a
lot of money from Robert Maxwell and
like that's not how money works. You
don't inherit the money. You inherit the
transational network and so the question
then is okay let's just speculate. Okay,
and I don't know for sure but what is a
potential source of Jeffrey Epstein's
wealth? And I if I were to guess I would
guess maybe the Shabbat Lubich movement.
Okay. Shabbat Louich. Who are these
guys? Well, these guys are religious
Jews who came from um Eastern Europe,
Barus, Ukraine, that area. They
immigrated to America in the beginning
of the um 20th century. And they own all
the real real estate in Brooklyn.
They own all the real estate in
Brooklyn. Why? because
they pull their resources
and they believe they have a meant
calling to save humanity. So they take
their wealth and they store it in real
estate. Imagine how much wealth they
they generate this past century, right?
They they started buying real estate at
the beginning of the 20th century in
Brooklyn and now they own all of it
basically. Now I I don't know if it's
all of it, but it's most of it. And then
they can use this real estate wealth to
do what? Well, they can um promote their
agenda in Washington DC.
They can find agents like Jeffrey Epste
to promote their agenda. Okay. So that's
what billionaires are. Billionaires are
agents, representatives of different
transnational networks.
Another point I will make is this. We
know for a fact that Lesie Wexner
gave power of attorney to Jeffrey
Epstein.
Right? So the idea is once you have
power of attorney, you can do anything
you want with this guy. You can actually
institution
if you want, but you have control over
all his finances.
And you're like like who does that? Like
like like you're billionaire and you're
still saying, you know, you don't have
any issues, but you sign over poverty to
this guy Jeffrey Epstein.
And it doesn't make any sense unless you
think that they're actually just agents
of a transnational network
>> and it doesn't matter who the agent is.
>> You said uh the greater North America
project. Do you think America will
become a theocracy by 2030?
>> Right. So again, there's a civil war
going on and it's about alliances.
Um right. All right. So, transational
capital is the greatest power right now.
And so, you need to form an alliance to
counter transational capital in America.
An alliance that seems to be forming
right now is alliance between the tech
sector
and Christian nationalism
as exemplified by two individuals, Peter
Theel and JD Vance.
Right? So, Peter Theo is a tech
billionaire and he goes around talking
about the Antichrist a lot.
And there's talk of how you can actually
create God through AI. You can make AI
sent sentient and then it becomes God
Godself. Okay? So, there's perhaps a
convergence between Christian
nationalism and um AI. Okay. So, think
of their vision for the world is this.
Think of the Handmaid's Tale but
digitized.
>> The Henmaid's Tale is a book written by
Margaret Atwood and it was made into a
TV series and it's set in the future um
after America has fought a disastrous
civil war and um the population is very
low. So what they need to do what they
need to do is create as many babies as
possible. And so and so what happens is
that powerful men are assigned a herum
and these handmmaids are basically you
know sex slaves to these powerful men
who are often in a in a in a military
>> right but behind this is the idea of
Christian nationalism
which is that America should become a
theocracy because how do you explain um
the system and the answer is because it
is God's will because this is this is a
system that allows us to most worship
ship God. Women should be at home making
babies. That's God's role for them. Be
fruitful and multiply. That's what it
says in the Bible. Go read the Bible.
Right? And then what you do is you add a
digital component to it where every
headmade is given a microchip. And this
microchip becomes almost like a um
guardian angel or maybe um a soulmate.
And this microchip is digital ID,
digital currency, digital surveillance,
right? At the same time, it's talking to
you all the time, giving you comfort,
giving you solace in in in in yourself.
ChachiBT is doing exactly that where
um whatever fantasy you have, Chachi
ChachiT just reinforces your fantasy. It
doesn't actually negate your fantasy. It
just reinforces your fantasy. Right? So
that I think is a future that they want.
I'm not saying they will achieve it, but
what I'm saying is that's the future
that they're moving towards. The concept
you're talking about leads into what
2045 could look like. Before we get to
2045,
uh there's three concepts. I'm curious
if you think it's important to talk
about these. So, it's America collapses,
uh, Russia takes Odessa, uh, NATO
collapses,
and then there's a conflict between
Japan and South Korea. Do you think any
of those? Yeah, I mean I mean, it's all
aligned together, right? Where it's all
part of this larger framework between a
globalist and a nationalist because NATO
represents a globalist, right? So, how
how do you destroy NATO? You force them
to fight a war in Russia. They can't
possibly win.
Right. So, so Europe is militarizing uh
reintroduc reintroducing the draft. Uh
Germany just announced that if you are
between the age of 17 and 45 and you're
a man, you cannot leave Germany for more
than 3 months without permission. They
just announced that I think today. Um so
Germany is moving towards a war uh um
setting and and they'll probably
introduced the draft at some point.
Okay. But again, we have to understand
this. This is a war between the
globalist and the nationalists. The
globalists want to maintain power.
They're willing to sacrifice any uh
anyone in order to maintain power. The
nationalists want to assert their
national sovereignty. Right? So Putin is
clearly on the side of nationalists and
the NATO represents the uh the
globalists. Um and this conflict is
going to spill all around the uh the
world. It's going to lead to civil war
in America. And the civil war will never
stop because Tensor Capital is really
powerful. They they'll have resources
everywhere around the world. So imagine
in 2030 to 2040, okay, these 10 years,
how the world is structured. Okay? You
have Donald Trump trying to establish
the North America uh tank, the greater
North America project. Okay? And uh you
have Russia establishing something
called the third Rome. Okay? that that
is their esquetology where they think
that Moscow is the third Rome after Rome
and Kasanapole and there'll be no fourth
Rome right but then you have Pax Judea
rising and Pax Judeica is where
transnational capital will base a lot of
their strength and resources right
because think about this where if you're
a trillionaire or a billionaire and
you're looking for the next great
investment opportunity the Middle East
is the best place why because the war
the war will devastate the entire Middle
east and so you will have to rebuild. Um
the Middle East is the hub of of all
trade in the world. So if you are Russia
and you're trying to access Africa, you
have to go through Israel, the Lavant,
right? And third of all, you have all
this oil and what is oil good for?
Powering data centers which allows you
to build build the AI surveillance
state. Okay. So trans capital is like
Paka, greater Israel. That's where we
want to put our money.
>> All right. So um pack transational
capital re reassert itself in packs
Judeica but it's not going to give up
the world it's still going to fight
Russia it's still going to fight America
right it's still it's still going to
exert authority over East Asia right so
tational capital is very good at at sto
soaking conflict by creating chaos
that's how they generate generate their
their uh wealth right so but remember
like as this is shaping um it's a
dynamic situation in that each nation is
trying to assert its sovereignty,
control over the entire world and that's
going to lead to a lot of conflict. But
then also we have to remember like
um a lot of these nations in Latin
America will not enjoy being taken over
by the Americans. So you'll have
insurgencies funded by Paka National
Capital,
>> right? Europe is not going to go away.
It's it's going to continue to fight
Russia.
And in a time of nuclear war, there will
be no like World War I situation where
armies just clash in the night and kill
each other. Okay? What it's really about
is trying to use uh misinformation, use
propaganda,
uh use psychological warfare to
undermine
the domestic elite,
>> right? So going back to Europe where
there Europe's going to bring out in a
civil war between the right and the
left, right? The left will support the
globalists. the right will want to
assert national sovereignty and Europe
will become a um proxy area
and then East Asia will also be in a
similar situation and at the same time
the transnational elite will try to
undermine both Russia and America by um
funding insurgencies by creating civil
war. So so it's going to be a very
chaotic situation. So do they think that
America will collapse by 2030 or roughly
like 10 years from now? Um the the goal
is for America to collapse because um by
collapsing America, you can reset
America, right? So once America
collapses and all this wealth is
destroyed, then it's easier for you to
move your capital back into America and
buy things on the cheap, right? you can
access their because America has has a
lot of wealth. So New York, Boston are
destroyed. But you know what? America
still has water, oil, resources, land.
So do you predict that will happen? Um
or that's just their interest? I think
these people, the elite,
are not as smart as they think they are.
I think everything's going to blow up in
their face. I think transnational
capital is in decline. I think their
empire is over.
I I think transational capital will be
dead in 10 years time.
So by 2045 uh and this is where it gets
interesting.
What do you think happens in 2045?
I